Vodafone?
Vodafone, perfekt! Sehr schön, nice.
GG Eats.
Ja Vodafone hatte keinen Bock mehr.
Die haben sich gedacht...
Piss dich Aldo!
...dachte sich Vodafone so.
Die wollten nicht mehr.
Aber jetzt gehts wieder.
Alles wieder gut.
Ich refresh mal den Chat.
Ja die USB ist ausgegangen, genau.
Nice.
So sehr schön, geht wieder alles, oder Leute?
Test, test.
So, wer noch nicht F5 gedrückt hat, F5 drücken.
Geht wieder.
Bambusbjörn, danke für den Sub.
Nee, das war Vodafone.
Ich musste OBS sogar abschießen.
Weil überhaupt keine Verbindung mehr gescheit funktioniert hat.
Ok, wir gucken das Video weiter.
Also wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Kurz, kurz Sound ausmachen.
Genau, wir wollen uns angucken, was da drinnen ist.
Fritzbox am Start.
Jo.
Da oben, es ist nicht Fritzbox.
Warum auch nicht?
Irgendwas, irgendwas muss da ja
Internet Einwahl und Zeug machen.
Ok, auf gehts.
Die Pfeife doch übrigens, so sollten die Batterien mal kaputt sein.
Also dann weißt du ja auch gleich Bescheid.
Ansonsten hängt hier am Surfer
noch eine externe Festplatte dran.
Das heißt offiziell Offside Backup,
dass wenn dir die Bude hier irgendwie
abraucht oder
immerhin.
Ich finde das gut, dass die sowas machen, weil ganz ehrlich
niemand von den Leuten, die das beauftragt,
also die Unternehmen,
die sie da betreuen,
die haben ja da gar keine Ahnung von.
Das heißt, du kannst da nicht drauf warten,
dass der irgendwie sagt, ja aber
richte auch mal
Offside Backup auf,
richte auch mal Offside Backup ein.
Offside Backup liegt auf dem Onside Backup?
Nee.
Nee, das hat er nicht gesagt, oder?
Oder mal gucken, mal gucken.
Muss man mal anhören.
Aber das finde ich gut, dass sie dem das einrichten, weil das
beauftragen die sie ja so garantiert nicht.
Weil die es nicht wissen.
Side Backup, dass wenn dir die
die Pfeife doch übrigens,
so sollten die Batterien mal kaputt sein.
Also dann weiß sie auch gleich Bescheid.
Ansonsten hängt hier am Surfer
noch eine externe Festplatte dran.
Das heißt offiziell Offside Backup.
Ja okay, Offside Backup.
Offside Backup an der externen Festplatte
vom Surfer ist jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen optimistisch.
Dass wenn dir die Bude hier irgendwie abraucht
oder abbrennt,
dass du
noch irgendwelche Daten hast.
Hä, das funktioniert doch, aber
da muss irgendwas fehlen
in dieser Aussage, weil
wenn die Bude abfackelt und das Server da dran
auch, dann fackelt doch auch die externe Festplatte
dran ab. Oder verstehe ich
das jetzt nicht?
Ah, die rotieren die externe
Festplatte.
Ah, okay.
Die machen die Festplatte dran, Backup
und dann nehmen sie fest. Das ist eine gute, das kann man machen.
Das ist die manuelle Variante.
Das ist aber durchaus in Ordnung.
Warum nicht?
Das ist doch in Ordnung.
Das finde ich okay. Ich meine
sinnvoller wäre es wahrscheinlich, wenn man
den Kram irgendwie übers Internet backupt.
Aber wer weiß wie die Anbindung
da am Arsch der Welt ist.
Warum nicht? Ist doch in Ordnung, kann man doch sagen.
Kann man doch machen.
Lukkizu, danke für den Sub.
Rotieren heißt
manuell austauschen. Ja, so würde ich
das interpretieren. Die stöpseln halt die
Festplatte ab und zu mal ab und starten
dann wahrscheinlich in neu, also eventuell
machen sie es so, keine Ahnung.
Full Backup inkrementell,
dann bis die Festplatte voll ist und dann Festplatte
weg und dann nächste Festplatte dran.
Full Backup inkrementell bis voll ist. Keine Ahnung
wie sie es machen. Oder ob sie alle Wochen
Full Backup machen inkrementell. Gar nicht warten bis sie
Festplatte. Keine Ahnung.
Kann ja alles sein. Aber ich finde
das ist eine super Geschichte. Wer weiß
was der hier für eine Anbindung hat. Vielleicht kann der seine Sachen
gar nicht gescheiten, die Cloud Backupen.
Weil die Internet Anbindung zu schlecht ist. Man weiß es nicht.
Kann man jetzt viel reininterpretieren, wenn der Tag
lang ist. Aber ich finde das nicht verkehrt.
Besser als nichts.
Und ich finde es gut, dass der das
macht und dass der das dem eingerichtet hat.
Weil du kannst nicht darauf warten,
dass dich der Kunde mit so was
in dem Fall beauftragt. Weil der weiß es
ja auch nicht besser.
Da musst du schon ein bisschen vorausdenken.
Und deswegen ist es auch ganz gut,
wenn die so Leute haben, die das machen.
Die kennen die Betriebe dann auch. Und die wissen dann auch
wie viel Knowhow ist da vorhanden
oder gar nicht. Und was ist am besten für die.
Und vor allem
auch in welchem Budget darf das
Ganze liegen. Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich eine legitime
Variante. Möb, danke für den Sub.
Rein.
Das ist ein bisschen
Scheiße.
Noch ein Digitus-Schrank.
So ganz kleiner
Scheiß eigentlich, der in 5 Minuten
erledigt sein könnte. Dann dreh ich durch.
Ja, das regt mich auch auf. Dreh dann wirklich durch.
Ich dreh da am Rad, geh da in die Luft, schimpf alles zusammen.
Ich raste aus.
Das... Mich regt auch
Kram auf, der funktionieren müsste, aber nicht funktioniert.
Einfach draufhauen, das hilft am meisten.
Einige sagen, er
braucht das überhaupt. Ist das nicht für meinen
kleinen Betrieb mit 100 Sitzplätzen und
5 Leuten in der Küche zu viel?
Also eigentlich ist das von Haus aus, wenn man gleich...
Das ist eigentlich so Minimalstausstattung.
Also wenn du wirklich willst und dass es auch
drauf ankommt, dass der Kram eben funktioniert,
eine USB und irgendwie
Backup, das nicht im gleichen Haus mit abfackelt.
Wenn du einen Betrieb hast, wo
dann auch Geld dranhängt, deine eigene
Existenz im Zweifelsfall, die Existenz des
Mitarbeiter und sonst noch was, vielleicht gehört
dir ja auch das, was auch immer.
Dann sollte eine USB
und zumindest die wichtigsten Daten
Offside Backup eigentlich das absolut mindeste
sein, was du machst. Die meisten machen das nicht,
weil sie keinen Plan haben. Deswegen finde ich
es gut, dass sie das dem so eingerichtet haben.
Richtig anfängt und
groß denkt doch oft besser in der
IT, als wenn man sagt, ich kaufe jetzt ein kleineres
Gerät, einen kleineren Surfer und dann reicht es ja plötzlich nicht
mehr. Jetzt am Ende sind wir halt auf
dann zwischen 14 und 45.000 rausgekommen
und das ist halt auch jetzt nach
Corona nicht so
einfach. Na ja gut. Je nachdem, was
sie da haben, wenn das also
ist immer die Frage, ist das mit
ist das mit Mitarbeiterkosten?
Ist das mit
allen Materialkosten sowas? Wer
weiß, was die da gemacht haben?
Ich meine IT Infrastruktur, dazu
gehören Desktop Geräte, dazu gehören
Drucker, Telefone, Monitore,
Server, USVs,
Racks, Kabel, das ganze Zeug einbauen,
dann ist das schon
also da ist das durchaus
im Rahmen, da kannst du nichts sagen.
Weil es ja nur ein
Teil der Kostenstelle. Ich kann mich
da natürlich reinversetzen. Sie haben
Heidengeld investiert und alles steht und fällt
mit der IT. Die Besonderheit
hier ist noch, dass die eine Schankkontrolle
haben, das heißt, ich sehe, wieviel hat
der Hahn rausgelassen und wieviel ist in der Kasse drin
und wenn das nicht boniert ist, sagt der Hahn, du kriegst von mir nichts.
Nicht,
dass die Bedienung sagt, hier du
kriegst heute was umsonst.
Da muss knallhart kontrolliert
werden. Hier kommt ein Kassendrucker
hin und hier oben hängt halt wieder
so eine WLAN Antenne. Das Thema
Administrator ist eigentlich auch gar kein Ausbildungspunkt.
Die haben auch komplett
WLAN und Verkabelung und so
gemacht. Da kannst du schon mal, das
verstehe ich, dass es jetzt 50k kostet.
Das ist quasi ein smarter Zapfhahn sozusagen.
Eine technische
Ausbildung gemacht. Ich bin eigentlich gelernter Automobil
Kaufmann und das hat sich damals
mit einem Audi Autohaus
in die IT-Abteilung gewechselt
bin und bin dann über einen Bekannten
zu meinem jetzigen Chef gekommen.
Ich bin ein typischer Quereinsteiger, ja.
Dann hören wir uns die Tage. Alles klar.
Vielleicht gibt es da irgendwie
so eine Art Gehen oder so, wo es heißt,
man kann mit Menschen gut umgehen oder man
kommt mit Menschen gut. Ja, ich nicht.
Klar, versuche immer ganz witzig zu sein
und nicht wirklich angespannt einfach eine lockere Atmosphäre
zu schaffen. Ich hasse andere Menschen.
Ich will nicht auf einer Wellenlänge zu sein.
Zerlegst du jetzt das ganze Büro da unten oder?
Kili?
Wo bist du denn?
Also bist du da hinten.
Die mit dem Kreis.
Das ist der Azubi. Es ist der Azubi.
Bäm, war klar.
Eines muss man diesen kleinen Klitschen
auch mal wirklich lassen.
Das sind meistens auch Läden,
die wirklich ausbilden, die nicht einfach nur immer
sagen, ha, Fachkräftemangel.
Oh ne, wir finden keinen.
Aber ausbilden wollen wir auch nicht.
Die haben meistens eins, zwei, drei,
vier, zwanzig Azubis.
Witzig.
Als Einwurf.
Dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung
gemacht habe, also bei dem
Provider, da
hatten wir, glaube ich, zwischenzeitlich
30 Azubis.
Das war aber
System. Das war quasi
Ausbeutungstaktik. So nach dem Motto,
die Azubis machen die Sachen
besonders billig.
Wie viel
am Ende da geblieben sind, kann ich schlecht
beurteilen. Also ich war ja auch
nur, glaube
nach
meiner Ausbildung noch zwei Jahre da.
Wo ich dann keinen Bock
mehr hatte. Dazu habe ich ja mal ein Video
gemacht, warum ich da weg bin.
Na ja, egal. Da Azubis am Start.
Aresing und die anderen
sind...
Solang du den Überblick hast, also
ich verstehe dein System nicht, aber solang du den Überblick
hast...
Also deswegen auch diese Farbaufkleber
hat das irgendeinen Sinn.
Ich kriege 3,94 Euro
aufs ganze Monat, weil er
so viel Geld kostet. Ich verdiene
aktuell 3200 Euro brutto.
Das sind nach Abzug knapp
2100 Euro netto.
Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass
wir alle immer zu viel wollen, teilweise.
Und dass es uns eigentlich eh viel zu gut geht.
Aber ich denke, so auf
Dauer muss das schon noch...
Naja, also es soll eigentlich viel ist, das jetzt nicht.
Gerade in München, aber okay.
Umgehen.
Ich habe jetzt einen Spitzel
abgeholt, das ist der Flo und wir schauen...
Also erwähnt das mit dem Porsche wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit nichts.
Dass wir uns einmal die Woche oder so abends
mal zusammensitzen, nehmen wir ein bisschen Ratschen.
Ich zahle aktuell warm, also
in allen Nebenkosten knapp 87 Euro.
Und das ist für die Verhältnisse
hier bei uns eigentlich recht günstig.
Also er hat mal zwischenzeitlich eine Wohnung gesucht.
Und du hast unter 1200 Euro nichts gefunden.
Also ich habe anderthalb Jahre nach einer Wohnung gesucht.
Du hast es ja mitbekommen.
Das merkst du dringend Herr Hindlmayr.
Aber wisst ihr, was viel wichtiger ist?
Dass der happy ist und zufrieden mit dem, was drum herum läuft.
Ansonsten...
Wenn es reicht,
für das, was er machen will, ist es doch
absolut ausreichend. Ich meine...
So zur Abwechslung ist
noch mal ein bisschen was drin.
Aber normalerweise hat der Getränke und Licht.
Das ist jetzt
so typisch bayerisch hier, Alter.
Wir kennen uns von der Schule, wir sind aber alle gemeinsam
bei Roten Kreuz.
Da bin ich jetzt auch den Monat recht viel im Rettungsdienst gefahren.
Nebenbei ehrenamtlich.
Und da habe ich den Monat knapp 180 Stunden
im Rettungsdienst runtergerissen, aber noch mit
160 Stunden normal gearbeitet.
Und das war...
Aber was für das Alter zurücklegen kann.
Und nicht damit dazuzählen,
wenn es halt ausreicht für die wichtigen Sachen
und man zufrieden ist.
Anstrengend jetzt, jetzt reicht es dann auch wieder.
Nächster Monat wird entspannter.
Dann nehmen wir mal...
Wir machen ganz basic
Hotdogs. Geht schnell, kostet nichts.
Macht keinen Dreck.
Die kochen zusammen, da geht es rund hier.
Richtig...
Kasse Würstchen.
Also ich investiere schon,
in Anführungszeichen, natürlich schon
viel Geld in Technik. Also diese...
Hier die Soundbar, den Rücklautsperren, das kostet
gut Geld. Kann mich rundherum
nicht beschweren. Ich komme mit meinem Geld gut aus.
Ich habe tolle Freunde im tollen Freundeskreis,
einen tollen Arbeitgeber, den ich auch wahrscheinlich
für mehr Geld nicht einwechseln wollen würde.
Und...
Ich bin froh, wie es momentan läuft.
Ist doch nice.
Ja, Altersvorsorge
ist aktuell anscheinend nicht drin.
Ah, ETFs, oder?
50 Euro ETFs, ich erkenne es nicht so genau.
Browser,
Mann.
Da oben.
Ja, ETFs.
NFTs.
So 40 Euro Versicherung, ja, wahrscheinlich das
Mindeste, was...
Naja, also man muss halt ehrlich sagen,
also ich denke mal, gerade in München
sind
2000 Euro
nachdem du Steuermotor zahlt hast
und sowas jetzt wirklich nicht viel.
Also ich kann es ja mit meinem
Gehalt vergleichen. Ich kriege mehr
im Monat bei 4 Tage
arbeiten. Also an...
Und nachdem Altersvorsorge
und sowas schon weg ist.
Das ist aber auch
Frankfurt. Ich denke mal, das kann man...
Frankfurt und München kann man was Preise angeht
ähnlich vergleichen. München ist wahrscheinlich noch
ein bisschen teurer. Also so
viel ist das für München wirklich nicht. Aber
wie gesagt, das Wichtigste ist, dass er mit über die Runden
kommt, dass er zufrieden ist mit seinem Leben und dass er eben
halt auch alles bezahlen kann, was
er so bezahlen muss. Dass er nicht nur plus minus null
auf dem Konto oder sogar mit Minus auf dem
Konto am Monatsende dasteht,
sondern
die Sachen gut hinbekommt. Und Happy ist, das ist doch das
Wichtigste.
Und er scheint doch gut drauf
zu sein. Also es scheint nicht zu sein, als geht es ihm
irgendwie schlecht. Das ist doch
das Beste, was einem passieren kann.
Mehr darf es immer sein.
Das war mein Tag als
Systemadministrator. Ein Tag in meinem Beruf.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Und wenn ihr selber mal
bei Lohnt sich das mitmachen...
Da darf er aber auch keine Freundin finden. Warum?
In der heutigen Zeit ist es doch wirklich nicht zu viel
verlangt, wenn die Freundin ihren Kram selbst bezahlt, oder?
In der heutigen Zeit, wo du teilweise schon Anschiss
bekommst, wenn du in den Stuhl ran rückst
oder die Tür aufhältst, dann kannst du auch von
ausgehen, dass es bestimmt genug gibt,
die ihr Leben selbst finanzieren können, oder?
Natürlich ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Und man hat übrigens sogar seine
Freundin im Hintergrund gesehen.
Kurz in dem einen...
in dieser Szene hier.
Guckt mal.
Am Anfang hat man glaube ich
seine Frau gesehen.
Im Hintergrund. Es könnte aber auch irgendeine vom
Aufnahmeteam gewesen sein.
Kann er sein?
Oh, Kerz, ja.
Soll ich mich auch mal bei
Lohnt sich das bewerben, Leute?
Nee.
Dann wird man mich ja sehen. Und dann ist
Wupplik angesagt. Nein, nein, das mach ich nicht.
Ich vergesse.
Das...
Das könnte ich komplett knicken.
Lohnt sich das Face Reveal.
Ein Tag in der
Deutschen Bank mit Max. Wer sagt denn, dass ich in der Deutschen Bank arbeite?
Wie kommt ihr denn auf sowas?
Deutsche Bank kein Quatsch.
Der Typ... Also eins muss man ja mal wirklich
sagen, gell? Die...
Das ist auch so gell. Das ist auch so typisch
hessische, doofe Redewendung.
Die IT Leute, die die hatten, waren
in der Regel relativ sympathisch.
Also wir hatten... Wir hatten
ihn jetzt hier. Wir hatten
ihn hier, der Streamer. Wir haben...
Wen haben wir noch geguckt?
Nochmal einen Streamer.
Ja, den kann ich mir auch noch dran... Lehrer, der war
auch echt sympathisch. Gut, das
hängt... steht und fällt natürlich auch damit, wie der
Beitrag gemacht ist.
Was verdient
ein Discord Mod? Das hatten wir
auch geguckt. Da kann ich mir jetzt nicht mehr so dran erinnern.
Der war auch
cool, der Typ, der auch... Also im Prinzip
das... Ja, die IT
Leute. Wen ich überhaupt nicht sympathisch
fand, war die Projektmanagerin.
Ähm...
Wisst ihr noch, die, die Excel-Tabellen gemacht hat
den ganzen Tag?
Wo war die denn?
Projektmanager...
G Beda! War das, glaub ich?
Oder? Ich weiß es nicht, man.
Die, die, die Excel,
Exel Consultve.
Das mag er aber wahrscheinlich nicht mal an ihr,
sondern am Job, dass ich das nicht
sympathisch fand.
verdient ein max fps mod die anerkennung des chats das muss reichen hast du das video über das
rechenzentrum vom bauer gesehen nee habe ich nicht derauer warum ist das er ok ich weiß warum
aber das erste was man bei google im auto komplett hat der bauer freundin ok ich war wir wissen alle
warum aber trotzdem wird schämen wird schämen wir besuchen 52 minuten das kann ich mir nicht
angucken jetzt das ist zu lang das ist zu lang 52 minuten nee das kann ich jetzt nicht gucken
usf aus mit autobatterien oder was ist das ist aber nicht hetzner wo ist er denn hier
kosa nee wo ist er denn da oder aber o o edith ist das die ist das doch der oetker
also leute das gucken wir uns vielleicht an aber erst später und nur wenn ich noch
kein hunger habe und wenn ich dann noch eine stunde durchhalte stunde video gucken ist mir
jetzt zu lang und wahrscheinlich habe ich dann hunger vielleicht gucken wir das irgendwann anders
die lidl ja das weiß ich dass lidl cloud provider werden will beziehungsweise ja schon ist ich
kenne sogar einer war mal bei lidl IT technisch also nicht im regale einräumen und ja die lidl
IT sachen sind sogar relativ das ist sogar relativ groß die haben lange schon keine
barbecue pit boys mehr gesehen ja das stimmt gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an aber mal gucken ob
sie noch gibt ob es ne ne ja die gibt es noch in a miracle of time ich hoffe ich habe das jetzt
halbwegs richtig hinbekommen gekonak lep hell yeah lidl cloud ist jetzt auch für
die öffentlichkeit verfügbar was kostet das stack it zeigt mal her was preise was
kosten dann der vm colocation preise ok in elhofen was kostet das da serverraum nein nein nein ich
brauche kein serverraum ich brauche einfach nur ein he oder so reise preise preise cloud
das ist lidl leute lidl lidl cloud einfaches preismodell ok container in windows server was
ist mit dem linux server ane compute engine ist in dem fall ok ist eine echte vm 219 ja ok und was
wie weiter das ist schon mal verwirrend gemacht colocation leistung ein halbes rack wie viele
he sind das 20 oder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 18 22 wo steht denn das wo steht das
ach da ach da ich gucke nie überschriften an überschriften ist meist useless na ja 300
euro im monat für 22 schöneinheiten ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so direkten vergleich
im kopf aber mein bauchgefühl sagt mir das ist ganz ok tiny server ok eine vm cpu also eine
virtual cpu und 512 mb ram 2 euro 19 ganz ehrlich das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht wenn man wirklich
was mini mini minimales braucht man kommt damit nicht wirklich weit aber die frage ist ob es
eine feste ip hat oder nicht oder ob das irgendeine natt gedöns ist oder so also wenn du da eine
richtig echte public ip 4 4 davon dafür bekommst ist das gar nicht mal so verkehrt
weiß ich jetzt nicht ob das der fall ist ja ist das dedicated oder schert das ist wahrscheinlich
also ich vermute mal als es unten drunter ist auf jeden fall schert der esx cluster oder oder
der kvm oder was das ist und die cpu ist bestimmt die auch nicht garantiert vielleicht der ram keine
ahnung so vergleichen wir das doch mal kurz mit hetzner ich würde jetzt ja eigentlich sagen
ausrufe zeichen hetzner in der ausrufe zeichen hetzner im chat dass ihr euch einen dass ihr euch 20
euro startgutschein startgut haben sichern könnt aber mein code ist abgelaufen da funktioniert
nicht mehr prices also gucken wir mal die kleinste geschichte bei hetzner ist eine cpu 2 gigabyte
ram was haben wir hier damit so wie eine cpu 2 gigabyte ram compute optimized server das kostet
einfach dreimal so viel ok ja dann nicht warum ist das so krass teuer auf einmal warum kostet
es denn das dreifache von dem auf dem verstehe nicht warum ist das so teuer das das wird für
mich da nicht in frage kommen netcup ist auch ok aber netcup aber das netcup wo ich wo ich nicht
hin wollte aber wie hieß dieser eine anbieter der den ausweis eingescannt haben wollte war das netcup
die die sich gerühmt haben dass sie so eine krasse denos protection haben es war nicht strato
es war nicht kontabo was war das denn o v h o v h war das ja genau o v h ja genau ich habe
witzigerweise ich habe genau den gleichen surfer bei strato ne nicht strato jonas ist das strat
ich weiß ich habe genau die eins und eins ist das oder ich habe genau den gleichen ein euro für
cpu genau den gleichen habe ich auch gekauft da läuft ein public mqtt surfer drauf sonst nix
ja die wollten irgendwelche ausweise eingescannt haben und so da hatte ich keinen bock drauf würden
die postident machen mit video ident oder so das wäre ok aber den ausweis ein scan per mail
schicken und sowas das war mir das war mir zu wirtschamp das wollte ich nicht doch das sind
die wo letztes das rechte strato abgebrannt ist doch genau die sind das ja jetzt nach werbung
mache ich erst wieder wenn wir das mit dem sponsor endlich mal wieder hinbekommen haben
ansonsten ist jetzt natürlich immer noch nicht schlecht aber startgutschein und sowas gibt es
erst wieder wenn wir das meintlich auf die reihe kriegen ich habe ich habe vor zwei tagen mit
hetsner geschrieben aber da ist es noch nichts rausgekommen dabei lief das letztes jahr ganz
gut aber gut wenn ich will der hat schon ja was soll ich machen ich habe keine ahnung ich
meine power shell nicht so also wo sind wir stehen geblieben mein eigenes video kurz
refreshen gucken was uns youtube youtube noch empfiehlt eigentlich will kein interview mit
einem pausen darf suchen gucken bettel fied wir lassen uns bettel fied gebeten das ist
not apple.com wir lassen uns wir lassen uns apple wir lassen uns level cap gebeten das
muss einmal die woche muss das sein der level cap gebet 20 42 were data mind max pain 1 & 2
are getting remakes xbox game pass remakes max pain 1 & 2 sind eines für mich immer noch eines der 2
der besten spiele überhaupt wobei max pain 1 finde ich wirklich ist immer noch story technisch
erzähltechnisch auch mit den comics wirklich geiles game leider ist es halt grafisch nur ziemlich
naja sagen wir mal nicht gut gealtert ja max pain 2 ist immer noch ganz hübsch
ist das rockstar mittlerweile also max pain 1 & 2 war remedy ich glaube nur ich glaube
nur max pain 3 war rockstar
die einzigen vier maps die wir jemals bekommen werden in diesem spiel locations launch dates
or other info that could help pinpoint what these maps will offer temporal suspects drained
might be based on concept art for 2042 and shows soldiers storming down a nearly dried up riverbed
alongside a much larger game hat ich sag ja gar nichts dass das game nichts hätte werden
können aber das game ist nichts geworden die hatten durchaus interessante ansätze aber nichts
draus gemacht oder noch nicht mal eingebaut lights out may be a reference to a prison or barracks
this could hint at an operation locker remake possibly dark lands could be another map remade
ist ja ein ein punkt ein punkt den ich immer noch etwas verstörend finde zu im nachhinein
battlefield 2042 das ist wenn man sich jetzt mit die twitter accounts angeguckt hat von den
entwicklern die haben ja vor release zum release und nach release übelst gut über das game
gesprochen und ich glaube das war nicht fake ich glaube die meinten das wirklich ernst also ich
gehe davon aus dass ein großteil der leute die daran mitgearbeitet haben wirklich den eindruck
hatte sie haben den krassesten shit seit 20 jahren abgeliefert und da frage ich mich halt wieder wie
entfernt wie weit entfernt kann man von der realität eigentlich wirklich sein ist die sind die sind
komplett ja out of touch aber komplett portal based on port valdez or panama canal from beck das heißt
heißt das wirklich port valdez ich habe gesagt port valdez aber wahrscheinlich moment ich wollte
wie spricht man das pronunciation guide
valdez das ist pronunciation guide und dann ist das irgendeine computer generated stimme
valdez ist das schlecht das ist in alaska ich dachte das in südamerika oder so wenn das in
alaska ist dann kann ich mir sogar vorstellen dass sie das ausstellen können dass sie das jetzt
richtig aussprechen können
company to again there's all kinds of speculation on temporary else part he previously data mined a
map called exposure and recently found high resolution artwork associated with it that map
is expected to launch with the season 1 update this before battle 42 launched dice published a
blog post saying that the games first year of live service would include new locations
and updates to portal mode the season 1 launch is only the beginning yeah they are
because it's not like we're coming an update however was delayed to give dice more time to fix
launch issues that's why they haven't said anything about the new maps coming to 2042 or when we can
expect significant additions to portal halo infidels recent updates have also been data
mine miners discovered a new game mode called last spartan standing the description says you'll
be able to level up your loadout by earning personal score it will be a big team battle mode
many speculate that this will be in finance rumored battle royale component loading the game
offline will expose this mode in the private match options previous data mines discovered
references it's mega krass wenn du solo spielst mit maus und tastatur dann kommst du gegen andere maus und tastatur leute ok aber sobald du gegen ich hab ja auch eine ganze weile
hallo infinite gespielt wenn du gegen controller leute kommst es ist mega krass es ist also das ist ja
eines der aubertunten aim assist die ich je gesehen habe das klebt an dir das also du kannst also das
ist wirklich das game was zeigt dass controller besser funktionieren kann als maus und tastatur
wenn man das halt so krass aubertunend dass das klebt das klebt an dem gegner mit wenn du mit
controller spielst also wenn du bei
kennt ihr noch mal ein kleines kennt ihr noch mein helm kennt ihr noch mal einen geilen sniper clip
der habe ich auf twitter gepostet mein sniper clip dann nehmen wir jetzt mal zum vergleich
gleich media
wo habe ich denn wo habe ich denn mein sniper clip
das ist doch nicht so lange her als ich den gepostet hab so und den den gucken wir uns mal an twitter alter
no god no god please no no no no ok
habe ich dem schox geschrieben glaube ich gerade schox sniper
ja
ja so also das ist das ist das ist wo ihr bräuchte ein bisschen haben glaube ich sogar im stream
gespielt hallo infinite so das ist jetzt maus und tastatur also du sie man sieht es klebt nicht am
gegner es ist einfach ein bisschen leiser weil sonst laber ich du musst halt einfach auf den
gegner zielen so das heißt wenn der gegner seit steppt dann bist du auch erstmal nicht mal auf
dem gegner drauf weil du weißt ja nicht dass er jetzt seit steppt da musst du erst nach aim das
ist mit dem controller nicht so mit dem controller bleibt ein ziel bleibt ein fahnenkreuz einfach
obwohl der gegner seit steppt einfach dran kleben so guckt euch mal mein krasses geschneiberer an
schneiber steigert jetzt jetzt passt mal auf leute ja ja max cringe alter
zack erst mal nicht gemisst so hier würde es auch komplett am gegner kleben bleiben du
musst nicht manuell aim es bleibt einfach komplett am gegner kleben mit mit mit controller
das wäre mit dem controller dreimal easier gewesen
erst mal 360 machen ja
allein schon dass man das nachführen muss und das ist mit dem controller nicht so
na gut das war lucky
ja so das wäre viel viel einfacher mit dem controller gewesen und das ist das ist zu
übertrieben das ist wirklich zu krass deswegen hatte ich ja auch kein bock mehr drauf also
konsolen aim controller ist ein halo infeld wirklich richtig richtig übertrieben
battle royale mode including a voice clip of the games announcer sing battle royale max payne
one and two are getting by their original developer entertainment they're being made
in partnership with rockstar games who publish max payne 2 and developed max payne 3 three makes
are being developed as a single package for pc playstation 5 1 ist halt nicht gut gealtert das
einzige was die leute heutzutage noch von max payne 1 kennen ist glaube ich das face
ich glaube das können sich die da können sich die meist noch dran erinnern an die face texture
von max payne das ist übrigens sam lake das gesicht das ist der der ich nenne zwar drehbuch
schreiber von remedy für die games und dem haben sie einfach ein foto von ihm im ersten teil drauf
geklebt in the xbox series consoles rockstar is financing development and remedy are treating it
as a full-blown production on the same level as their much more of an actual remake than
unfortunately there's no release date of course development is currently in the concept phase
ubisoft officially ended support for ghost recon breakpoint and announced a new ghost recon
point breakpoint warte mal ist breakpoint das neueste das letzte mit den drohnen was
so beschissen war wo ich wo ich sogar in sponsored video zu gemacht habe ja das ist das hat keine sauer
interessiert das video verstehe ich auch aber stonks wildlands war da vor ja das war ja angeblich
ganz gut ja weiteres service game wo reingeschossen hat im is in development it's currently code
named over and has been in development for over a year some speculate that it could launch as
early as next year and of course players are wondering exactly what type of game it'll be
many fans felt that breakpoint was a significant departure from the hardcore tactical gameplay
compared to the games it expanded on wildlands open world adventure aspects but dropped core
features like ai teammates and introduced a level based weapon system post launch updates added
ai teammates in a mode that removed all of the leveling systems in favor of weapons with fixed
stats as updates and the rest of the games dlc expansions pushed it in the right direction but
also announced a rainbow six mobile it's a port of rainbow six siege that'll offer a very similar
experience built for portable devices the reveal trailer footage is exactly next-gen looking but
it's a significant improvement compared to hundreds of siege clones already on the market there's no
really state for six mobile yet I always ask myself how they imagine that you control the shit with the controller
touch screen properly so that it's fun but apparently it works well enough that the casuals
don't bother with it for playtesting are available on the games official website the online multiplayer
modes for dark souls games might be permanently offline they were disabled in january so developer
from software could work on fixing an issue with online services in february they said the servers
would be restored after elden rings launch but we're a month out now from elden rings launch and
still no word on restoring dark souls servers recently the steam entries for all three dark
souls titles had their online co-op and online pvp categories removed the same players can edit
so it seems likely that the dark souls franchise is either a long way off from getting its online
modes back or they're just gone forever xbox game pass might be getting a family plan that supports
up to five users at once the service exploded in popularity over the last few years but the
court is nice ich meine du kriegst eh schon relativ viel für dein geld im xbox pass wenn du das jetzt
noch für deine family members freigeben kannst übrigens gerade mit thema family member was ich
nicht verstehe ist also ich benutze ja wenn ich mein fernseh drüben benutze eigentlich hauptsächlich
nicht für fernseh gucken sondern entweder über amazon was gucken oder im twitch youtube gucken und
jedes mal wenn ich die amazon prime video app aufmache muss ich sagen ob ich das bin oder kinder
zugucken da fack warum kann man da kein default speichern jedes mal wenn ich diese app öffne
muss ich sagen ja ich bin es es gucken keine kinder zu was ist das warum kann ich nicht sagen die
fault ich bin es es gucken keine kinder zu value has always been the depth of its library and low
cost adding a feature like family plans could massively boost the appeal for people that share
a console with friends or family the new plan hasn't been officially announced and is just an
industry insider rumor for now but that rumor suggests it would be revealed wirklich kinder
zu ja aber das ist auch nicht der job von amazon mich dazu belehren die ganze zeit und wenn ich
der meinung bin kinder dürfen sich filme ab 16 angucken dann darf ich das entscheiden ja das ist
auch mein problem was ich ausbaden muss das ist halt es geht amazon und scheiß an world of tanks and
world of warships developer war gaming is leaving russia and belarus due to the ongoing conflict in
ukraine the company ich rede nicht von der amazon app auf dem handy amazon app auf android tv
he fired a creative director for publicly supporting russia's invasion and temporarily halted all
advertising of their games to make changes that respect the victims their studio in saint petersburg
has been made an independent company also was ich mitbekommen habe ist das aus fifa und ich
glaube aus mehreren aber bei fifa weiß ich also in fifa kannst du glaube ich keine russischen
mannschaften mehr spielen oder so das haben sie schon angekündigt schon vor vier wochen oder so
reiner marketing move natürlich ja reiner marketing move aber das world is world of tanks ist das
nicht in russischer entwickler aber wie heißt er war gaming sind die nicht irgendwie aus
ach nee zyper ok das habe ich jetzt durcheinander gebracht
the region war gaming is also closing their biggest studio location which is located in
mink's all of the active projects and obligations will be distributed to other studios owned by the
company they'll be providing severance and support to all affected employees to summarize the
situation is a gar nicht gefallen hat ist als mcdonalds weg ist da gab es ja noch mal
riesen schlange von mcdonalds weil die alle noch mal ein pickback fressen wollten
an you mental shift for wargaming which is not a small studio their belarus studio was the
country's largest game developer and all of their games had something to do with their mink studio
luther shooter escape from tarkov is getting in video aiai nach zypern deswegen habe ich im
hinterkopf irgendwie dass sie aus russland kommen okay ist es weiß russland oder belarus
aber weiß was wir gar nicht mal sagen stimmt da sind die umgezogen ich hatte nämlich im hinterkopf
irgendwie gedacht die kommen doch aus russland scaling tech dlss in an update soon battle state
game ceo said during a recent live stream that the implementation is ready and to expect it in the
games next patch based on a presentation during the stream you could potentially see double the
fps with dlss enabled in tarkov and that is a massive win for the players since the game
tends to be incredibly demanding in general survival fps rust got ziplines in a new rail line network
the ziplines are found near power lines that are already scattered around the map unfortunately
the new rail line system doesn't have functional trains yet that's coming in a later update the
ultimate ist ist dieses deutsche russ tun ja eigentlich vorbei ich habe das nur am rande mitbekommen dass das dass das stattgefunden hat wer hat
er gewonnen weiß dass jemand er ist vorbei goal is to make the rail system fully procedural so
dass man die das bestimmt nicht weil sie so menschenfreunde sind auf einmal wahrscheinlich
weil es steuerliche vorteile gibt oder eben weniger probleme das machen die nicht weil sie so nett
sind die pay raise with a minimum salary of 20 dollars an hour being full time also gives them access to benefits
and a bonus plan employees at raven software which is activision's current warzone developer went on
straight after the studios qa team suffered surprise layoffs the affected employees had been promised
better pay and permanent positions for months before being let go the strike lasted for several
weeks and culminated in the remaining qa workers filing to become a union activision says
converting their qa staff to full-time employees has nothing to do with ravens ongoing situation
you a developers involved in a real kann man davon ausgehen um so sehr die sachen abgestritten
werden umso wahrscheinlicher sind sie das ist genauso wie in der politik wenn du irgendwelche
aussagen hörst du nach dem motto wir stehen voll hinter keine ahnung xy setze namen ein und und
wir wir wir sind voll dafür und wir stehen voll dahinter 100 prozentig auf dieser linie zwei
wochen später okay der typ ist weg schon oft genug gesehen also umso mehr dort quasi sich dahinter
gestellt wird und zugesprochen wird umso mehr das quasi gesagt wird umso umso weniger ist
umgedreht umso mehr ist bestritten wird umso wahrscheinlicher ist es unionisation effort
aren't eligible for the pay increase including them would involve meeting with the union
representatives but activision refuses to acknowledge ravens qa unionisation effort voluntarily
some response to the news on social media paint it as a union busting strategy by activision
before we get to our final story to bobby überhaupt nicht passen dass der was gegen
gewerkschaften hat this week i just wanted to say thanks so much for tuning in what game should we
keep an eye on for next week are there any upcoming fps titles or big updates that you're excited
about let us know wir hatten wir hatten hier eine interessante frage zu linux games habe ich
irgendwo irgendwo hier gesehen ja ja irgendwie will ich nicht zwei betriebsstelle haben haben und
auch nicht eins in einer vm deswegen überlege ich ob ich auf zocken verzichte nur linux putz aber
das ja das ist schwer zu sagen kommt darauf an was du machst aber sprich dann gegen linux in der
vm ich finde das ist die optimale kombination aus windows für alles was man so braucht inklusive
gaming und linux für den rest das läuft ja ziemlich gut in der vm wenn du nicht gerade
knall mit 3d beschleunigung verwenden willst ja das wird mich nicht wundern das ist not apple
punkt komm dot com point komm leute wann sagt man dort und wann sagt man point da sind sich die
amis selber ja nicht ganz einig irgendwie drüber ich weiß dass es dort ist aber warum ist es warum
ist es manchmal point point als kommer ok als zahlen wie man sagt point aber die sind sich
nicht einig ob man jetzt manche sachen als dort oder als point ausspricht also es ist 0.8 zum
beispiel ist nicht 0.8 aber es ist apple.com alles klar ja die amis haben sie nicht mehr alle was
das geht warum macht man punkt als als kommer na gut ich sag ja nur mal inches oder ounces für
für gewichte mein ounces wenn du bei amazon guckst willst du eine maus bestellen bei amis
dann steht dann da wiegt 20 ounces oder sowas ich weiß auch was so was 1 ounce ist ok freedom
units ja ok was gucken wir uns als nächstes an die battlefield friends gucken wir jetzt us
government wants to make it in a kokona teilweise interessiert mich das wow warum guckt er mich so
aggressiv an dem startbild don't shut down your computer warum nicht ok wenn da ist wieder
nichts dran wenn das ist irgendein blödsinn wieder dass das ist wieder in den schwachsinn
video ok schau aber doch doch das macht das macht sinn in den standard einstellungen macht
der beim shutdown ein wie heißt das s3 ne es vier wie heißt das wenn du den ram inhalt auf die
festplatte schreibst ram abbild auf disc genau explain why your computer is still running slow
and some of those issues are still not so wenn mein computer slow ist egal egal was fix well in
order for windows to work with its graphics card sound motherboard keyboard wifi gibt es wirklich
auch leute die den sound cardetrennen haben mouse etc windows relies on something called a kernel
this kernel thing basically enables your heart this kind of thing okay to work together you type a
letter on your keyboard and somehow it appears on your screen you click play on this video and
your speakers start to play the kernel is responsible for that it has complete control and therefore
it's always running in memory so when you click on shutdown your windows closes all your apps
logs you out of your computer and it seems like your computer is actually switched off however
what it actually does is keeps the kernel in the state of sleep hibernation so that when you press
that power button on windows doesn't have to reload the kernel it has all the info that he needs
and ta-da windows appears for you to log my god okay this is called fast startup wobei ich
wobei ich bezweifeln würde dass das wirklich so funktioniert
also ich würde eher vermuten dass der ganz normal erst mal booted bis zu einem
ziemlichen early summer early state in diesem bootzyklus also er wird ganz normal booten
bloß dass der dann anstatt komplett den normalen bootvorgang durchzuziehen irgendwann nachdem er
den kernel gestartet hat sich den inhalt wieder außen von der disk liest in ram zurück als
irgendwie als state snapshot oder sowas also ich glaube nicht dass das wirklich so funktioniert
wie man sich das jetzt in erst im ersten moment vorstellt aber weiß ich nicht keine ahnung
this is called fast startup and microsoft actually introduced this feature back in windows 8 days so
why should you care about this now since it doesn't work on every computer and every laptop you may
not be aware of it or maybe your computer hardware at the time didn't really apply to you but it may
apply to you now by not properly killing the kernel it means that if you have any issues such as your
sound stop playing all of a sudden or your one fire all of a sudden doesn't connect when you click
on that shutdown those issues still remain inside the kernel you should also care because when you
update some apps they require full shutdown to take effect das ist dann quasi stand by versus
reboot na gut aber auf der anderen naja
those apps therefore don't actually get updated because your system hasn't really shut down some
people also report issues if you're in your hard drive or you're trying to do boot system that
can actually cause corruption when it's in the state this is why those IT people always tell you
have you tried switching it off and on again a restart actually does it a restart actually
kills the kernel shuts everything down and you start up with a nice clean boot but what happens
if you don't want to wait man kann das einfach ausschalten nummer so nebenbei angemerkt also
man kann diesen dieses fast startup hybrid sleep und und hibernation und wie man kann das einfach
ausschalten your computer but you still want to go back to the good old days when shut down was
actually a shutdown let me show you what you need to do click on the windows and hold the shift
button as you click on the shutdown this will bypass so fast start up das wurde das wusste ich
tatsächlich nicht aber ich habe es komplett ausgeschaltet also noch kontakt vom friseur
ab und zu er schickt in your windows head down to the search bar and type the control panel
to be an icon that looks like this we want the section that says hardware and sound open that
app under the power option is that's not das alte control panel ist das wieder was was über das
neue control panel nicht richtig funktioniert alter microsoft warum warum ist das warum ist das nur
so schlecht warum ist das nur so mies an der court change what the power buttons do so like that
now you'll see turn on fast startup is ticked what we want to do is click on the option that says
change settings that are currently unavailable now simply untick this box click on save changes
and now when you shut down your computer it will do it the right way now note here if you don't see
fast startup option it probably means your pc doesn't support fast startup and is basically
shutting down correctly so no changes necessary for you now you can clearly see there's a mode
here called sleep and it's checked by default and there is another mode here called hibernation
which isn't checked what are these let me show you hibernation ist doch im prinzip mehr oder
weniger sowas wie fast startup oder hibernation ist wir schreiben den ram inhalt auf die festplatte
und ich dachte fast startup ist im prinzip auch so was in der richtung wie wir schreiben den ram
inhalt auf die festplatte vielleicht ein bisschen optimiertere variante let me show you so once
again head to the start button click on power and now you'll see it's added the little option
called hibernate hibernate ist hibernate nicht ein java db mapper oder sowas
die calculator on my desktop let's put a note so ich euch sagen was der beste
weg zum shutdown ist man holt sich eine steckdose die man remote schalten kann und dann schaltet
man einfach wenn man abends im bad steht und zähne geputzt hat ins bett will schaltet man
einfach die steckdose aus das ist der krasseste shutdown überhaupt man es kann natürlich sein
dass die windows installation nach ein paar wochen kaputt ist weil er sich mal irgendwann
verschluckt aber das ist ein richtig echter shutdown working apps before shutting down
now i click on start click on the power vielleicht ein bisschen chat frage vielleicht ein bisschen
random aber welchen dns server verwendet ihr für was du meinst für deinen also möchtest du
einen eigenen dns server haben für lokale namensauflösung oder meinst du welchen dns
server wir eingetragen haben um was weiß ich google aufzulösen also ich habe bei mir lokal
eingetragen einen mein mein router und der macht ein bisschen lokale namensauflösung also diese
mikrotikkiste die macht ein bisschen lokale namensauflösung und leitet alles was es nicht
kennt weiter ins internet zu 8 8 8 8 und backup 1 1 1 1
also chat die frage ich habe das jetzt ein bisschen blöd vorgelesen das war eine frage aus dem chat ich
habe dir zuvor gelesen als nach ich die aber nein das ist eine frage vom samuel gewesen im chat
welchen dns server verwendet ihr sleep all right switching over to an external camera
there is the sleep aber warum genau zeigt uns das jetzt ist das video sonst zu kurz oder wie
my screen goes black as it normally does let's make sure there's no more signal yep no more
signal coming from my computer to my screen let's go check out the actual box itself and you can
see my ram still flashing the stone empfehlenswert ja und nein also für mobile funktioniert es
teilweise wo es nicht funktioniert ist youtube twitch und und irgendwelche apps da klappt es
nicht gescheit und auf dem desktop würde ich dir eh empfehlen installiere ein adblocker browser
plugin also bei hall mag seine daseinsberechtigung haben aber so die universale lösung für alles
ist es nicht mehr in fed by my computer get that power button and then once i log in you'll be able
to see who cares einer was ein sinnloses video monka es man das ist noch apple.com ok ich
prädigte jetzt einfach mal ihr seht ich habe so nicht geguckt oder so ich prädigte jetzt einfach
mal was passiert in diesem video er hat eine adresse also er geht auf eine adresse dass es
aussieht als würde auf apple.com gehen aber in wirklichkeit ist nicht nicht apple.com sondern
es apple.com und irgendein emoji oder irgendein irgendein unicode zeichen oder so dass es aussieht
wie apple.com aber nicht apple.com irgendwie sowas vermute ich jetzt mal irgendwie sowas in der
richtung oder oder ein großes l statt ein kleines ne wobei domains ist eigentlich erst mal case
insensitiv da vielleicht vielleicht er könnte auch die host datei ändern dass er woanders
hinkommt egal gucken wir uns mal an es wird es wird nicht spektakuläre sein denke ich mal
this is apple.com rather at first glance it looks like apple.com but it's not ja außer wenn man
sich das außer wenn man sich das zertifikat mal anguckt sieht man das zertifikat irgendwo
das ist apple.com aber er kennt das wirklich nicht richtig das dann dann verwende der wahrscheinlich
irgendein anstatt dem l verwendet er wahrscheinlich irgendein unicode zeichen was aussieht wie ein l
aber gar kein l ist oder irgendwie sowas rather at first glance it looks like apple.com but it's not
it's a fake it's not owned by the company apple but rather this individual who bought the domain
name and hosted their own website as a proof of concept back in 2017 fortunately for all of us
instead of using it for malice and scamming everybody he decided to be a good person and tell the
security community about it to make sure that this wouldn't be an issue anymore in the worst-case
scenario what they could have done is make a website that looks like apple.com but is then sends
all the information to their own server instead of apples you know like passwords and credit card
info wait this seems like it shouldn't be possible because this is a huge problem right i mean
imagine clicking on an email saying in big bowl letters that your account is about to be
delivered and to click on klicken klicken auf links in emails ist ja eh immer bescheuert weil
das was angezeigt wird und das was das hinter stecken kann als link ist ja nicht schon die
letzten 20 jahre oftmals das gleiche on this link to keep your account now this piece of spam might
be scam but if it looks legit and the url bar says apple.com you might be inclined to believe them so
how was this even possible you can't have to apple.com that's not a thing otherwise the internet
would devolve into chaos where everyone can easily pretend to be everyone else the secret that's not
how you spell apple see when i spell apple as an apple.com i say a p p l e but that doesn't say
that. Das ist wahrscheinlich kyrillisch oder irgendwie sowas. That's the cyrillic letter. Haha ich wusste es ist kyrillisch
alter was sonst wieder diesmal wieder nicht die kina chinesen schon die rosen wieder alter
first letter is not the latin letter a you can see the confusion here right they look identical at
least in this font it does and as you can see this can be problematic now since then there have
been good defenses against this in the modern browser this post was made back in chrome 57 and soon
after in chrome 58 google released some changes to mitigate these vulnerabilities but let's dive
into this problem because it's one of those problems that has quite a few layers and it's
not a trivial problem to solve first off let's start off by saying that the internet also seit
dem an uni uni code domains machen kann kannst du eh ganz abgedrehten shit man also es gibt ja auch
also du kannst ja mittlerweile sowas hier machen ich punkte ich fühle das jetzt nicht aus weil
ich keine ahnung habe wo wir rauskommen die sache ist die unter der haube macht das da draus xn
minus minus minus kui bla blub ja ich gehe da nicht drauf ich weiß nicht wo man da rauskommt
keine ahnung lots of people use it and not everyone uses the same character sets so the trivial
solution of banning certain characters might be okay if your language doesn't use them but you
don't want to do that because if let's say you're a user in china and you just ban all chinese
characters from being in a url you're going to find that your user also wir wissen doch dass
ascii das einzig wahre encoding ist also im prinzip erlauben wir der fix ist ganz einfach wir
erlauben in urls einfach nur 127 standard ascii zeichen und die steuerzeichen fliegen raus also
im prinzip ab ist z fertig das muss reichen who cares kyrillisch griechisch chinesisch
einfach 127 zeichen sind genug für alles zahlen ach quatsch zahlen lassen wir auch raus brauche
mal alles nicht indisch thailändisch brauche mal alles ascii ascii only fertig
is going to plummet if you have any special rules where you're not getting the full web
experience because of the language you use in übrigens ich glaube das ist in domains auch
wirklich so ne weil ihr seht ja wenn ich unicode gedürnt hier rein mache der übersetzt das ja der
encoded das ja ich glaube domains sind wirklich ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber ich glaube
domains sind im prinzip wirklich ascii only something small like a warning it's still going to be really
annoying to use the internet hey it's a security versus convenience trade-off again you can imagine
that every single time you do anything mildly out of the ordinary your browser stops you by pushing
you to the spiritual equivalent of a tsa line but that of course would be really annoying if you want
to take a second to pause to think about how you would implement a good minus hier minus können wir
auch nehmen minus ist auch okay am minus ist auch die folgt ascii do so now as i talk about some of
our modern web browsers and how they go about doing it really think like a security developer how much is
this stopping attacks and how much is this hurting user experience we should also was interessiert
mich user experience we don't want to block access to the site we can show a warning of course but a
less invasive way is the url is suspicious or seems malicious or deceitful because of the characters
it uses did you do the anti-einsicht das einzig wahre verfahren um dass im jahr 2022 machen
ist blockchain ai und machine learning wenn schon dann richtig cloud native full stack
anders geht es nicht the url of the page into this format diagonal skaliert which makes it really
obvious that this is not really apple.com and is instead this other thing puny code is basically
a way for you to convert all international yeah genau das ist das was ich gerade gezeigt
hab set of characters of mostly symbols and latin characters there's a fairly simple algorithm
for this that we won't get into but instead of the vast sets of complex and overlapping characters
that exist in uni code we instead only have a hundred or so that are part of ascii anyways
one of the older solutions that existed was to only allow characters used in languages in the
user's preferred languages list so generally speaking if a user says that they use english and
spanish don't show them the urls if they contain korean characters in the url and vice versa
convert to puny code and move on it's not perfect like whenever you want to visit a page from
another language you have to whitelist that language in your settings just to see the url and if
you don't want to now all of your totally valid korean pages have really stupid looking urls and
so there was an effort to move away from these techniques that utilize language settings then
perhaps we should only allow urls if all the characters are from the same character set so
basically no mixing of different scripts in the url this would certainly solve this problem of
the fake a and no matter if this is richtig verstehe eigentlich gibt es das problem in
der form gar nicht mehr wir kriegen das jetzt historisch erklärt oder wie oder was okay
das muss man sich weiter angucken so was haben sonst noch zu bieten hier praktikum
beim bestattern das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht hin chat gab es noch irgendwelche questions hier
du block habe ich auch am start es ist übrigens teilweise erstaunlich wenn ihr youtube aufmacht
und eine weile wartet habt ihr irgendwann hier 200 geblockte dinger oder sowas drin das ist
richtig heftig das haben wir schon geguckt glaube ich das haben wir schon geguckt war das von dir ich
habe mich nur noch dran erinnert dass irgendjemand gesagt hat man könnte krassen klickbait titel
machen so dieses pixel spiel ist besser als und ich habe mir noch dieses pixel spiel gemerkt
das hat guter titel ja guter titel da gibt ich jetzt in sub für ich glaube das warst du ich erinnere mich ja
kauf abschließen ich hoffe es funktioniert weil ich paypal technisch nicht eingeloggt bin auf dem
zweiten rechner dachte ich aber geht dann so wupplos danke für den sub ja nice nein das
habe ich nicht gesehen aber das habe ich offen weil die leute gesagt haben wir sollen uns das
angucken okay leute okay okay ich mache euch einen vorschlag wollen wir wollen wir das rz video vom
bauer gucken noch eine stunde lang jetzt bevor ich mittagessen gehe oder wollen wir noch ein paar
kleinere videos gucken das video kenne ich habe ich schon geguckt rz rz wir gucken das rz video
okay vielleicht vielleicht machen wir es einfach so wenn es paar sachen gibt die ich nicht so
spannend finde im rz video dann ne das rz video schaffen wir bestimmt in einer stunde wenn ich
dazwischen dann gibt ich ein bisschen okay rz wir gucken rz ist egal wir kommen jetzt rz aber ich
gibt vielleicht ein paar sachen müssen wir mal gucken der aua wupp wupp wupp hallo zusammen
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren video wir sind mal wieder für euch unterwegs und zwar sind
wir laut genug in bielefeld ihr erinnert euch vielleicht das bielefeld Richtung januar kennt
noch irgendwer immer dieses bielefeld meme so aus den 91 und 2000 dass es das angeblich nicht gibt
das ist glaube ich kompletten vergessenheit geraten haben wir ja videos zu IBM power fünf
server gemacht ist ein relativ alter server IBM power pc und wir haben das so ein bisschen
angeschaut dass IBM ja ganz spezielle sachen macht die wir so gar nicht kennen wenn wir
einfach nur der x86 intel amd welt unterwegs sind und generell die topkommens bei den IBM
powerservern auf der information zu bekommen und dann nach dem video hat mich jemand von ödiv
angeschrieben grüße gehen raus an dominic vielen dank dafür für die einladung und ödiv war mir
vorher gar kein begriff wenn ihr aber dr ötter hört das kennt ihr alle denken wir an die
ofenfrische die so schön die pizza oder koppelrad und wiese benjamin blümchen torte wer kennt
sie nicht ja das sind die sachen von dr ötter und dr ötter ist ja nicht nur nahrungsmittel
war doch der ötter nicht auch die das mit der konkrefter kohle pizza oder war das war das andere
war oder war das verwechsel ich das jetzt war das andere
sondern klar das ist ein riesen konzern und die brauchen ja auch irgendwie it und die haben das
selber gemacht die haben es gab doch mal so eine youtuber pizza mit aktivkohle oder so ein youtuber
pizza kohle das sah richtig abartig aus
youtuber pizza
schwarze influencer pizza muss in die tonne genau genau das ding
und dieser richtig eklig aus diese pizza
nee nee nee nee nee nee die war die war schwarz die pizza das sah richtig abartig aus hat das
nicht sogar tanzverbot mal in dem video gezeigt das ding
lukapizza ja hier guck mal das wird diese mit diesem aktivkohle rand oder was das war
richtig eklig nee weiß nicht aber gut hat sich bestimmt verkauft
du bist doch nur neidisch weil er ein geiles produkt nur für seine fans gemacht hat korrekt
so ist es so wo sind wir das hier stehen geblieben video
wo waren wir denn hier jetzt ja ok wir müssen uns das video jetzt aber wenn wir das nicht
jetzt am stück gucken das wäre ich nie eine stunde fertig 1970 ich habe keine pizza ich
hätte jetzt gern aber eine pizza aber nur ordentliche pizza keine keine aktivkohle pizza
eine richtig richtige ordentliche wisst ihr wisst ihr was ich mag ich mag sardellen pizza
da sagen die leute immer i max wie kann man sardellen pizza futtern aber ich mag gibt es
chat gibt es noch jemand der sardellen pizza mag von euch oder umgedreht wer mag sardellen
pizza und wer mag keine wir machen eine umfrage wir machen eine umfrage ich mache eine umfrage
sekunde sardellen pizza so antwort ja ist dich alle ok abstimmung dauereine minute umfrage
beginnen inhalt erfüllt nicht die rechtlichen richtlinien was der inhalt erfüllt nicht die
richtlinien weil ich piss dich alde als antwort reingeschrieben habe ok jetzt funktioniert alles
ok also leute sardellen pizza ja naja oder piss dich alle piss dich aldo das ist salzig
ich mag dass das die so salzig sind ok also ja in kombination mit salami also mit so pepperoni
wurst ist auch pock also ich sehe wir sind so gespalten also die großzahl der leute also
weit überwiegend der leute mag keine sardellen pizza sagen wir mal so 20 prozent finden sie
nicht so wild und 80 prozent finden sie es eklig es fuck ja kräten sind nicht so schlimm
die sind so klein bei sardellen und so durch durch den ofen so durchgebraten merkste eigentlich
kaum was kaum was von ok also 20 prozent könnten sich vorstellen so was zu futtern 80 prozent
sagen nope no pass du hast ja so ein bisschen ich halte aus war mir ja klar ah gut also ich
mag sardellen pizza davon hätte ich jetzt gerne eine wo wir gerade dabei sind wir echt mal das
video gucken sonst kriegen wir das nicht fertig datacenter zu gründen für ihre eigene lebensmittel
alles klar und dann ich glaube 1995 wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe dann haben die ihr
unternehmen gegründet wurde auch als dienstleister auftreten für andere mittelständische und große
unternehmen hauptsächlich so in der datenverarbeitung und die machen fast alles mit
IBM power server die haben auch ein IBM Power 10 hier und das ist warum absolut kranker shit und
deswegen freue ich mich dass wir heute hier sein dürfen und vor pc es geht mir jetzt vor dem
rechenzentrum dass wir uns heute in diesem video anschauen generell machen wir zwei videos im
zweiten video ist der fokus eher mehr also ich meine die meisten wissen es wahrscheinlich nicht
aber die xbox 360 hatte auch ein power pc und die ps3 hatte mal von ihren compute course abgesehen
auch glaube ich dem power pc architektur aber die letzten zehn jahre fällt mir nichts ein was
irgendwie neu noch auf power pc setzt aber wir bauen da ein bisschen was auseinander schauen
uns ein paar einzelne geräte im detail an im heutigen video geht es jetzt erst mal um den
generellen generellen aufbau vom rechenzentrum das 2013 in betrieb genommen wurde wir schauen
uns an wie funktioniert die kühlung wie funktioniert die stromversorgung und so weiter der ganze aufbau
außenrum das ist sehr sehr spannend generell sind es zwei rechenzentren die ödiv in bielefeld in
betrieb hat die sind in einer art ring angeordnet das heißt die verbindungen zwischen den beiden
rechenzentren sind quasi doppelt vorhanden und sind absichtlich nicht direkt nebeneinander laufen
sondern in dem ring angeordnet dass wenn eine leitung mal beschädigt werden sollte die zweite
immer noch komplett autorik funktionieren kann und es auf gar keinen fall zu irgendwelchen ausfällen
kommen kann aber jetzt gehen wir einfach mal so weit so weit die theorie wir wissen ja dass
solche planungen das ausfälle verhindern immer bis dann bestand haben wenn mal was passiert was
man nicht geplant hat zum beispiel wenn der bagger kommt und irgendwie den abblick weiter was auch immer
kann immer mal was passieren aber ich gehe auch davon aus dass ja klar das stimmt schon dass
die viel geld reingesteckt haben dass das möglichst ausfallsicher ist anfangen wie kommen
die daten eigentlich in dieses rechenzentrum an dieser stelle möchte ich mich ganz kurz bei
cause bedanken denn cause ist der sponsor dieses videos und hat diese reise auch ermöglicht und
wir schauen uns jetzt mal ganz kurz die high end ddr 5 aber schweige von cause an für kompakte
und hochfunktionale systeme sind die korsens module mit niedriger bauhöhe und aluminium
hiesböder bestens geeignet diese sind mit einer kapazität von bis zu 32 mit modul und
einer geschwindigkeit von 5600 c 6 haben elgato gekauft vor zwei jahren in weiß erhältlich
falls ihr das also alles was jetzt auch beschreibung und damit geht es jetzt auch weiter mit dem video
generell ist es natürlich so dass man nicht so einfach in so ein rechenzentrum rein spazieren
course der vengeance genau relativ viele hürden die man nehmen muss viele türen und meistens
ist es so wie hier es könnte natürlich geht nicht genau ich komm nirgends rein wir stehen
jetzt an der sogenannten einspeisung das gibt es ja einmal links in grün die einspeisung ost
und rechts in rot einspeisen und das ist auch so ein bisschen eine besonderheit alles was wir
uns jetzt auch gerne einspeisen immer doppelt für ödiv ist auch nur dass es 100 prozent
leistung immer gibt egal was passiert und das beinhaltet auch dass das komplette rechenzentrum
quasi doppelt aufgebaut ist also alles was wir haben gibt es immer einmal in grün und einmal
rot wir schauen uns jetzt grün an einfach nur aus prinzip und starten mit wie kommt der strom
hier rein und wie kommen die daten der bereich hinter mir ist das wo die glasfasern ins rechenzentrum
hier ankommen wir haben hier einfach gesagt drei von diesen schwarzen großen teile eins ist die
verbindung ans normale internet wie ihr es kennt telekom zum beispiel eins ist die anbindung an
einen großen knotenpunkt in frankfurt weil man muss ja auch mit dem großen weiten internet in
der ganzen welt verbunden sein frankfurt frankfurt ist immer gut ich habe euch ich habe euch die
story die story mit dem pippo fat server im dc schon oft genug erzählt das muss ich euch
jetzt nicht wieder erzählen wir müssen das video gucken das kann man nicht durch in der stunde
verbindung an das andere rechenzentrum was wir gerade schon angesprochen haben nun mal so ganz
grob die verbindung ans andere rechenzentrum circa 500 gigabyte pro sekunde also schon sehr
sehr schnell und hier oben über mehr ist ordentlich das ist ordentlich drei fette leitungen drin da
ist die strom anbindung als rechenzentrum und zwar mittels ich meine 500 gigabyte das sind 400
gigabit das sind quasi vier terabit so ungefähr das ist schon doch das ist schon ordentlich
10.000 volt was daran auch wirklich irgendwie komplett mein blowing ist ist die tatsache dass
insgesamt von jedem rechenzentrum aus vier leitungen jetzt zum beispiel nach frankfurt gehen also diese
verbindung die ich gerade schon gesagt habe und die herausforderung dabei ist dass keine von diesen
leitungen die laufen nicht direkt zusammen gebündelt dahin weil es könnte ja jemand der
bagger der bagger die leitungen war es ist sondern die laufen alle irgendwo ganz woanders lang dass
die niemals zusammen laufen und wenn man jetzt mal überlegt bielefeld frankfurt ist jetzt nicht
direkt um die ecke dann ist es natürlich erstmal das physikalisch zu machen ein enormer aufwand
und man kann sich vorstellen das kostet wahrscheinlich auf den und dann geht in die leitung kaputt und das
switch spending tree baut sich neu auf und das netzwerk ruckelt erst mal drei minuten irgendwie
sowas 100 prozent ausfallssicherheit gibt es einfach nicht irgendwas ist immer ein oder anderen
cent solche langen verbindungen zu haben dass die sich niemals irgendwo über kreuzen oder sonst
was und das betrifft jetzt eben nicht nur die verbindung nach frankfurt sondern auch zum beispiel
zu einem anderen rechenzentrum die verbindungen die sind alle immer komplett getrennt voneinander
irgendwo kreuz und wehr gelegt dass die sich alle niemals unterscheiden dass ich wieder da
ist nie zum ausfall kommen kann da kam gerade aber was man daran schon mal gut sieht da ist
wirklich aufwand dahinter das ist aber auch auch ich finde eine sache erkennt man da wirklich
ganz gut eine sache kennt man wirklich gut sowas selbst zu betreiben richtig gut pause getroffen
hier also sowas zu betreiben ist natürlich richtig brutal aufwendig und daran erkennt man auch den
trend zur cloud finde ich an sowas erkennt man das ganz gut wenn man sowas wirklich richtig
hardcore ausfallssicher machen muss lokal und jetzt nicht nur ein server hat oder so das ist
aufwendig es fack das braucht massig personal das braucht massig geld das braucht lange zeit das
braucht viele ideen und hirn schmalz was da rein fließt also das ist nicht ohne und so als nur nach
15 klitsche holt man sich eine cloud kiste und ist mehr als gut aufgestellt und muss nichts mehr
selbst betreiben also ich finde daran sieht man es ganz gut warum es diesen trend überhaupt gibt
auf der anderen seite gibt es aber auch genug gute gründe dafür den kram selbst zu betreiben
auch wenn es zur zeit ja quasi fast schon verpönt ist zu sagen wir betreiben diese betreibt sachen
selbst aber gut ganz ein super cloud native auch nicht so drüber nachgedacht wenn man dann
unterschiedliche leitungen hat die dann da die verbindung zwischen bielefeld und frankfurt
zum beispiel haben dann gehen die über unterschiedliche wege sind unterschiedlich
lang da man aber schauen muss dass die signalwege immer am ende gleich lang sind weil es muss ja
auch irgendwo synchron funktionieren ja das heißt man muss an gewissen stellen dann die leitungen
künstlich verlängern dass die am ende auch überall gleich lang ankommen was der aufwand
enorm ja ein raum weiter deswegen decken wir das jetzt auch mal ganz kurz ab auch wenn das
setzt rein theoretisch eigentlich eher zu dem kühlungs aspekt der infrastruktur gehört haben
wir hier die wasser diabetik und hier wird wasser aufbereitet ich dachte erst dass ich zum ersten
mal hier reingeschaut habe dass dann das wasser hier drin ist aber das ist gar nicht der fall
sondern hier sind so salze drin die dann dafür genutzt werden das wasser wenn es durchläuft
zum reinigen also das wasser trinkwasser ganz normal was von außen ankommt hat z.b. kalk
und das darf nicht sein warum das der fall ist das schauen wir uns nachher an aber ich
werde auf dem dach die freiluft kühlung anschauen so weiter geht's technik wir kürzen den
stromweg jetzt ganz kurz ab weil eigentlich werden aus den 10.000 volt natürlich über
ein transformator 400 volt das sparen wir uns aber und gehen jetzt direkt zu der niederspannungs
anlage wir sind jetzt in der niederspannungs hauptverteilung und hier wird eigentlich nur
entschieden ob man jetzt die stromversorgung von außen verwendet quasi was von den startwerken
ankommt die 400 volt die natürlich vorher durch den transformator gegangen sind oder ob man auf
das dieselnot stromaggregat ja klar falls mal rein theoretisch stromversorgung zusammenbrechen
sollte von außen dann wird hier geswitcht von a nach b es gibt übrigens sogar dass das das wissen
viele nicht es gibt was usw angeht es gibt nicht nur usw mit batterien es gibt auch usw die sind
mechanisch die also mit denen kannst du dann keine kannst du da nicht zehn minuten lang was
betreiben aber es gibt usw das muss man sich so vorstellen das ist quasi ein gewicht genau das
ist quasi ein gewicht was im kreis sich was was im kreis dreht und wenn der strom jetzt ausfällt
dann dreht dieses gewicht noch eine weile weiter kreisel krein genau kogas sozusagen das war jetzt
genau das war kogas genau richtig an der position mit dem bild ich war natürlich zahnrad damit
ja das dreht sich dann weiter und bremst dadurch ab es ist ja nichts mehr da was was dieses gewicht
weiter bewegt aber diese paar umdrehungen die dieses gewicht noch macht reichen um die zeit
zu überbrücken bis der dieselmotor angelaufen ist also das gibt es ich würde sagen so verbreitet
ist das nicht mehr aber sowas gab es und gibt es auch interessant wirklich wirklich sehr interessant
sind diese roten schläuche die da oben auskommen das sind keine kabel oder sowas und das sind
tatsächlich schläuche und da wird kontinuierlich luft abgesaugt aus den schränken raus auch immer
dass aus jedem schrank genau die gleiche menge abgesaugt wird ist auch sehr wichtig weil man
darüber sind oben so hohe dran diese grauen und die gehen hinter mir in detektion also in
sensoren rein und da kann festgestellt werden ob kleinste partikel irgendwo sich in der luft
befinden die darauf hindeuten könnten dass irgendwo ein spätbrand am pfeiferzeug sich
ausbreiten ist also da kann die kleinste veränderung der partikel dann festgestellt werden um dann
entsprechend direkt vorzuwirken bevor hier ein großer brand überhaupt entstehen könnte was sich
einfach auch unfassbar durch dieses also brand im rechenzentrum weiß ich noch fand ich witzig in
meiner ausbildung wollten sie uns erzählen brand im rechenzentrum ist nicht schlimm weil da gibt
es ja kaum was was brennen kann das war sehr optimistisch also die meisten rechenzentren
die ich kenne gerade da wo man sich auch einmieten kann die haben eine eine löschanlage halt nicht
mit wasser sondern mit einem gas keine ahnung und zumindest ist das so du kriegst du kriegst
ich glaube es ist argon oder so nicht nicht nicht näher zumindest wenn du da reingehst dann
kriegst du wirst du aufgeklärt dass zum beispiel dass du quasi sobald das warnsignal zeit sobald
das warnsignal kommt hast du irgendwie 30 sekunden den raum zu verlassen ansonsten erstickst du so
nach dem motto also ist ja kann kann schon in die hose gehen ja kabel ist die ordnung also vor allem
wenn ich es mit meinem office zu hause vergleiche hier ist wirklich alles extrem akkurat gemacht und
das werden wir durch die ganze tour werden wir das feststellen können wie man jetzt auch gleich
ein bisschen hören kann wir sind neben der usw das ist immer dieses ekelige giechende geräusche
ist eben wichtig dass die spannung auch geordnet ankommt sehr geglättet ankommt in der guten
qualität und das was wir jetzt neben mir haben ist das heißt das was für die server zur
verfügung gestellt werden muss das gleiche gibt es noch mal eine minstige schranke filmen wir
gleich noch was ab für die gebäudetechnik für die infrastruktur weil die muss natürlich auch
abgesindert werden wir werden jetzt nicht so viel zeit ich glaube das geräusche erst mal schön
alles gepixelt von dem rechenzentrum ist das sogenannte online usw das heißt immer sehen die
rein theoretisch in der ausfallzeit von 20 minuten überbrücken nicht schlecht 20 minuten bei so
einem fetten ding ist krass die werden dauerhaft genutzt das heißt der strom von außen 400 volt
wechselspannung kommt in die usw geht da durch gleichrichter 20 minuten ist wirklich nicht
ohne also muss wieder zurück zu einem wechselrichter logischerweise damit das dann an die server
weiter verteilt werden kann wir haben hier 480 blöcke die in diesem raum stehen alleine für die
stromversorgung von den servers selbst jeder von diesen blöcken hat übrigens 6 volt spannung und
der vorteil von so einer online usw ist eben dass man egal was passiert wenn eben der stroma kurz
weg ist dann muss er nicht erst irgendwas anlaufen oder sowas sondern weil der strom die ganze zeit
durch diese batterien fließt ist auch in dem stromausfall von dem externen zulieferung
ist die stromversorgung sichergestellt also läuft das aber auch das problem dass durch
sowas natürlich der verschleiß an batterienhöhe ist weiter jedes mal das kenne ich ich habe
genau das gleiche problem bei solchen stahl was der hier ich bin aber gestern tatsächlich
rübergefallen muss ich dazu sagen auch wenn es so krass gekennzeichnet ist wenn man durch die
tür hier reinkommt ist hier so ein kleiner ring und ich habe mich gestern schon gefragt warum
gibt es denn eigentlich das ist eine gute frage weiß ich auch nicht aber die batterien die
enthalten ja säure und ja plötzlich alle von denen undicht werden alle 480 das wusste ich
nicht das ist interessant wir haben nämlich auch bei uns so ein ding und ich habe mich auch
gefreut aha ok das ist etwas genau neben der it auch die infrastruktur über batterien abgedeckt
werden muss und die höhe von diesem ring ist genau ausgerechnet dass wenn alle batterien ihre
säure verlieren dann steht die säure bis hier hoch das ist ja kultake dementsprechend auch
die versiegung 5 hat schon es gibt tatsächlich die türen die auch zu öffnen sein wir gehen
jetzt runter und schauen uns das notstromaggregat an bei den batterien die wir uns gerade angeschaut
haben ist es so dass wir minimal 20 minuten das komplette rechenzentrum betreiben können und das
ist jetzt und wo ist der pizzer hoffen viel batterien technisch gesehen aber eben nicht viel
wenn man denkt dass es eben 24 7 läuft und damit die stromzufuhr auch dauerhaft sichergestellt ist
wenn von außen kein strom mehr geliefert wird gibt es natürlich das ist ein stromaggregat 18
zylinder und warum ich meine hand hier drauf halte leider könnt ihr das natürlich nicht
fühlen aber das ganze teil ist warm gefühlt irgendwo zwischen 40 und 50 grad Celsius das machen
die auch dass das ding kann gleich hochdrehen weil das ding muss natürlich sofort anspringen
können das ding ist sobald das also wupp geht das an ja so ein teil haben wir auch bei uns ist das
ding nicht so fett von sieben sekunden ist dieses teil hier mit ca 1500 ps bei 100 prozent leistung
und kann dann das rechenzentrum komplett mit strom versorgen und da möchte ich nochmal in
erinnerung rufen wir schauen uns jetzt ja immer nur ein teil an das heißt alles was ihr seht auch
dieses teil existiert ja hier drin doppelt und kann das komplette rechenzentrum jeweils immer
versorgen das ist auch immer das was ihr nie vergessen dürft an dieser stelle ansonsten ist
es einfach ein überdimensionaler motor im prinzip genau das gleiche was in einem schiff oder so was
existiert braucht bestimmt auch gut diesel ja turbolader abluft hier die kühlseite von dem
motor das heißt hier ein größer ventilator genau das gleiche was man im prinzip im auto
hat hier nur in groß kühlung von dem motor hier die ansaugung also hier wird die frischluft
angesaugt geht hier schön durch den turbolader durch wird verdichtet und hier hinten die klappen
die öffnen sich dann in dem fall wenn dann eben das notstromaggregat anlaufen muss weil
es muss auch irgendwo frischluft zu vorgeben das heißt hier gehen dann die klappen auf und
dann kann schön luft direkt zu dem notstromaggregat und dann wird es ja was ich mich frage ob die
regelmäßig das aggregat testen also ob die quasi jetzt auch auch testen mit der umschaltung ob das
alles funktioniert oder ob das management da sagt so nach dem motto zu hohes risiko wir verlassen
uns drauf dass es funktioniert im ernstfall wenn wir hier rüber gehen dann haben wir hier so ein
kleinen zwischen bei uns ist es immer eine riesen diskussionsakt ob dieseltest oder nicht dieseltest
so ein riesen teil 18 cilinder hat natürlich auch ordentlich verbraucht 240 liter diesel pro
stunde würde mit diesem tag natürlich nicht lange halten das reicht aber auch für ein paar
minuten und draußen ist dann noch mal ein tank der mehrere 10.000 liter fast und dementsprechend
kann das rechenzentrum dann auch lange betrieben werden das notstromaggregat wenn es leer geht
werden erst mal alle azubis zur tankstelle geschenkt auf azubis kommt der geland 40 azubis los
erstmal im kanister bei aufgefüllt aber nicht nur das ganze jahr rum und macht nichts sondern alle
zwei wochen wird es eines der zwei notstromaggregate getestet da tatsächlich sicher ist dass in dem
notfall auch alles sicher läuft weil man will das ja nicht an jahre lang rumstehen lassen und dann
hat man vielleicht ein zündkerzen problem ich weiß es nicht genau aber deswegen werden alle nur das
aggregat getestet oder wird auch das umschalten getestet im abstand von zwei wochen also nach zwei
wochen wird das getestet und danach zwei weiteren wochen das andere notstromaggregat dass man immer
sicher ist egal was passiert dass alles sicher funktioniert wir befinden uns jetzt ein bisschen
mehr im zentrum vom rechenzentrum das heißt wir sind relativ nah an den servern dran die
wir uns dann jetzt demnächst auch mal anschauen werden hier über mir habt ihr jetzt stromtrassen
auch da sieht man wieder grün und rot also links und rechts von diesen stromtrassen und da laufen
jetzt die 400 volt erst mal weiter es wird ein bisschen lauter wir sind schon mehr an den
servern dran links und rechts von mir hätte man dann auch server über mir seht ihr jetzt gibt es
solche abgangskästen aus diesen sie sind quasi einfach gesagt verteiler geht dann so ein richtig
fettes kabel raus also ihr seht so abendige kabel die links und rechts raus das ist sehr
ordentlich muss man echt sagen die dann über den server schränken also bei uns wir haben auch
natürlich kabelführung an der decke aber bei uns siehst du da wirklich die kabel drin liegen
sind dann meistens orange glasfaserkabel oder auch kupferkabel also siehst die kabel das ist
nicht so ordentlich wie hier was ist auch interessantes links und rechts haben wir teile
der kühlung das heißt wir werden jetzt auch gleich weiter das thema kühlung beleuchten weil
wir haben ja so ein bisschen den weg vom strom verfolgt und um die kühlung so ein bisschen
einfacher zu verstehen gehen wir erst mal kurz zu dem server link zum video hier kühlungsweg
weiterverfolgt jetzt sind wir natürlich in einem krass lauten bereich versucht es immer so kurz
wie möglich für uns zu halten manchmal geht es aber muss man auch sagen verkabelung sieht auch
schon alles sehr ordentlich aus das habe ich schon deutlich schlimmer gesehen ich habe leider oder
ich kann es euch wahrscheinlich nicht zeigen ich habe bestimmt ich habe glaube ich noch eins foto von
unseren alten wenden wo die ganzen kabel rausgekommen sind und gepatcht wurden das sah wild aus das
sah wirklich wild aus im alten rechenzentrum also das war ganz ganz wir also hast du teilweise
zehn minuten gebraucht bis du das richtige kabel gefunden hast wo es rein und wo es rausgeht
ja das hatten wir bei uns auch dass sie nicht richtig zu ging und so die türen wurden bei uns
gar nicht mehr zugemacht wird es leider nicht mehr gehen aber dafür sehen wir was sehr sehr
interessantes das wahrscheinlich von euch und auch ich noch nie gesehen habe aber erst mal
jetzt hier oben kommt dann der strom letztendlich an für die server ihr seht auch die boxen sind
einzeln gelabelt mit 63 ampere das heißt jede von den leitungen die runter fließt an einem
einzelnen schrank 63 ampere zur verfügung stellen natürlich auch hier wieder rot und grün das heißt
jeder schrank ist doppelt versorgt und wenn wir jetzt mal hier so ein schrank mal aufmachen das
sind die gleichen schränke die wir früher auch hatten mit diesem komischen drehhebel vielleicht
ist das aber auch einfach nur sehr beliebt aber der hebel erinnert mich sehr stark an die an das
alte als hat von früher natürlich auch einfach es ist beeindruckt es ist wirklich sehr sehr
ordentlich zieht sich wieder das grüne durch also ihr seht hier die grünen kabel auf der rechten
seite sehen wir die roten kabel und wenn es so ein server zum beispiel zwei netzteile hat für
die redundante versorgung ist ein IBM kisten ist aber auch die versorgung das sind eindeutig
IBM kisten dass der ganze server auch auch die die gelben die gelben klipse an den netzteilen
schreit sehr IBM server selbst redundant das heißt ihr seht ein grünes kabel einmal von der grünen
zufuhre und einmal ein rotes kabel für die rote zufuhre dass auch nicht nur die netzteile natürlich
redundant sind sondern auch die komplette stromversorgung die dahin fließt und hier
schließt sich jetzt ein bisschen wieder der kreis von ganz am anfang als ich über die IBM
power geschichte erzählt habe denn hier neben mir haben wir einen IBM power 9 das blaue schreit
auch IBM server 1408 kerne 64 terabyte ram also schon ein bisschen was ist ein bisschen was ja
um noch mal zu der stromversorgung zurückzukommen das teil 16 kW leistungsaufnahme pro stunde das
merkt man auch mal davor steht es schön schnuckelig wofür braucht er das er braucht das gar nicht das
ist das rechenzentrum von dr. oetker von der vorderseite schauen wir uns auch gleich an und
diese 16 kilowattstunden die merkt man eben auch wenn man es davor steht wie ich da kommt
halt wirklich viel warme luft raus und so kommen wir das ist übrigens also ich habe ja auch lange
zeit in den in den in den gängen das von rechenzentren zugebracht wo die abluft hinten
rauskommt und also das krasseste angebläse bisher was ich da erlebt habe an IBM playcenter voll
bestückt wenn du dort ein netzteil austauschen wolltest dann haben immer alle lüfter hoch gedreht
weil das hat dann gesagt netzteil raus volle pulle also die lüfter waren so krass dass wenn du
das muss ich vorstellen ich meine ich meine vor zehn jahren war ich vielleicht noch nicht ganz so
oder zu meiner ausbildungszeit war ich nicht ganz so pepo fett aber ich war sicherlich nicht irgendwie
40 kilo leichtgewicht oder so also ich habe hinter den servoren nicht nicht gekniet wie
nennt man diese ich war so in der hocke füße auf dem boden und wenn du das netzteil raus
machst und die lüfter voller pulle angehen in der kiste vor dir du musst dich wirklich in den
luftstrom rein lehnen dass es sich nicht dass es dich nicht nach hinten um pustet also da kommt
schon ein bisschen luft raus also bei denen jetzt weniger die sehen jetzt nicht so mega krass aus
von lüftern passt ja auch nicht so viel rein aber erkennt man nicht aber playcenter haben wirklich
ein ziemlich krassen luftstrom wenn die alle hoch drehen kühlung denn auf der vorderseite
kommt halte luft rein hier betreten jetzt so verleiht dass es schon wieder lautes hier
betreten jetzt die kaltgang einhausung das bedeutet unter mir in dem gang ich versuche
das so kurz wie möglich zu machen aber unter mir in dem gang durch dieses pita rost da kommt
halte luft mit überdruckt nach oben das heißt die kalte luft ist von unten raus woher die kommt das schauen wir uns gleich an
bei uns war das umgedreht bei uns kam die also bei uns war das die vorderseite der
schränke war bei uns außen und innen drinnen kam die kam die warme luft raus das sieht innen
drinnen sah es ungefähr so aus wie hier halt nur offen innen drinnen kam die warme luft raus und
wurde dann wurde dann weiß ich was damit passiert ist kann ich wieder in die klimaanlage rein oder
so also bei uns war es genau umgedreht also trotz dass deswegen ist es so laut die ganzen
server auch richtig viele lufte haben natürlich selber luft ansaugen ist es natürlich so dass
unterschiedliche server je nachdem was sie für eine leistungsaufnahme für den kühlungsbedarf haben haben die
unterschiedlich stark gelüfter und es muss natürlich sichergestellt sein dass ein server
der vielleicht hier hinten ist und ein bisschen weniger kühlung bedarf als die tower 9 maschine
dass er auch noch ausreichend kühlung bekommt ja kommt es eben mit deutlichen überdruck heraus
und wird dann durch die server schränke durchgedrückt in diesem raum hier waren wir gerade schon mal also
über mir sind diese abzweikästen für die stromversorgung von den servoren und hier stehen
auch um luft klima schränke unscheinbar aber in diesen schwarzen schränken wird die warme luft
die oben haben die keine rgb lüfter ja stimmt warum verzichten die auf extra performance verstehe
auch nicht reingezogen wird also die warme luft steigt von den servoren auf kommt hier durch die
gitter hier rein in diesen raum wird oben in diese schränke angezogen in diesen schränken sind
filter drin erst mal die luft filtern und wenn man sich die filter anschaut dann sieht man so
viel ist da gar nicht zu filtern ich würde fast vermuten so was gibt es bei uns auch habe ich
noch nie gesehen fast sauber das muss man auch einfach festhalten hier staub existiert hier
einfach nicht ja das stimmt durch die filter also nach dem die luft ist auch eklig heute wenn
ihr mal ein paar stunden am tag in so einem rechenzentrum gewesen seid also da kannst du also
hast das gefühl du wirst krank du wirst nicht wirklich kann oder hast das gefühl du wirst krank
also es ist keine schöne atmosphäre nee atmosphäre ist das fall also es ist keine schöne ja kein
schönes klima da drin von eurer wasserkühlung da fließt kaltes wasser durch dieses kalte wasser
kühlt dann die luft die da durchgezogen wird wieder und dann hier unter mir im boden ist
dann wieder die kalte furz trocken die luft diverse lüfter dann wieder weiter verteilt und kann dann
eben wieder zurück zu den servoren fließen und diese platten auch wenn die auf den ersten
blick aussehen wie irgendwelche ganz leichten künstler platten ich kann euch versichern so
leicht sind die tatsächlich gar nicht ja die sind tatsächlich sehr schwer ja und wenn wir
diese platten mal anheben jetzt mal nur beispielhaft dann sehen wir unten drunter eben die ganze
vorrohung also da wird dann das kalt wasser zu diesen schränken geliefert das ist eigentlich
normal das ist eigentlich auch weil das so doppelten boden gibt das gibt eigentlich
keine rechnung wo das nicht so ist und wir werden jetzt ein bisschen den weg verfolgen
wo kommt dieses kalte wasser her in diesem raum hier war es eigentlich es haben eigentlich fast alle
so doppelten boden wo unten drunter rohre und und sachen gehen strom trassen und hinter mir in
den rohren haben wir zweimal kalt wasser ist eigentlich auch ganz witzig er sieht kalt wasser
fließt weg kalt wasser fließt zu aber wenn man sich jetzt das thermometer mal anschaut auf der
linken seite sehen wir eine temperatur von 14 grad Celsius und auf der rechten seite sehen wir
temperatur von 20 grad Celsius und das ist auch ganz witzig das sind eben die guten deutschen
normen beides ist eben wenn man das nach deutschem recht betrachtet beides ist kalt wasser es gibt
natürlich irgendwo eine grenze ich weiß nicht was die grenze ist vielleicht 40 50 grad oder so was
ab wann man dann irgendwas als heißwasser bezeichnet aber beides also das ist die seite die dann zu den
zellern fließt also zu diesen beides kalt wasser aber eins ist wärmer als das andere weil es vorher
einmal durch die technik durch geflossen ist wo er geflossen ist oder durch die durch die
klimalage geflossen ist das zu wasser mit 14 grad Celsius und das ist dann quasi das warm wasser
mit 20 grad Celsius was dann wieder heruntergekühlt werden muss aber beides wird eben als kalt wasser
bezeichnet aus dem rechenzentrum raus seht ihr kommen die normen das so sagt machst du nix zum
verwaltungsgebäude geleitet denn das komplette verwaltungsgebäude wird auch mit dem warmwasser
sage ich jetzt mal also ist eigentlich kalt wasser belabelt aber mit dem warmwasser was zurückkommt
geheizt das heißt durch so ein heißkörper im winter mit 20 grad ist aber nicht so wahnsinn
damit zur folge dass das gebäude nicht immer die gleiche temperatur hat und im sommer weil
das wasser auch verhältnismäßig kühl ist kann mit diesem wasser dann gleichzeitig auch gekühlt
werden wir sind ja gerade den rohrleitungen gefolgt die das kaltwasser quasi beinhalten das
heißt die wärme von den servoren die muss abgeführt werden letztendlich und das passiert
hauptsächlich hier also primär möchte man natürlich das hier zu machen wir haben hier im
prinzip riesige radiatoren das gleiche was ihr bei eurem also quasi quasi sowas wie elefantenohren
um das wasser wieder runter zu kühlen genau das gleiche hat man hier machen elefanten ja auch die
die leiten das blut durch die oren und wählen dann mit den oren zum sich zu kühlen nur einfach
ein bisschen größer wir sehen hier die ganzen damellen da sieht man da gehen die rohrleitungen
durch wohl dann das wasser durchfließt das ist allerdings ein anderer kreislauf nur mal so als
info das wasser was jetzt durchläuft dann hier runter gekühlt im idealfall wenn es jetzt kalt
ist wie jetzt gerade sind sogar die lüfte die oben drüber sind aus das sind lüfter wenn es
wärmer wird bis zu 12 grad Celsius kann man mit den kühlern so wie es hier ist bildungsauftrag
fps wenn es jetzt ein bisschen wärmer wird dann gehen irgendwann die lüfter wieder an damit man
das wasser wieder auf temperatur hält wenn es im sommer ganz warm ist da kommen jetzt wieder zu
der geschichte vom anfang wo wir diese großen grünen tanks hatten wo das wasser aufbereitet
wird dieses wasser wird von hier auf die lamellen drauf gesprüht und dann hat man einfach eine
verdampfungskühlung weil er verdampft durch den phasenwechsel wird wärme entzogen und das benutzt
man dann hier im sommer wenn es sehr warm ist wenn das ist wirklich high IQ konstruktion benutzen
will dann kann man über diese verdampfungskühlung dann trotzdem die außenkühlung weiter verwenden
wie bei den anderen sachen auch ich habe schon zweimal erwähnt oder dreimal ich weiß es gar
nicht alles ist hier doppelt und auch die kühlung ist logisch weise doppelt die ist auch auf der
anderen seite vom gebäude da ist gerade sonne das ist auch so ein kleiner fun fact an der seite wir
stehen jetzt im bereich der im schatten ist und deswegen wird primär diese seite verwendet weil
da scheint keine sonne drauf dementsprechend ist es hier ein bisschen kühler ich ist es wirklich
kalt und deswegen wird diese seite auch benutzt und die seite wo jetzt gerade die sonne drauf
scheint da wird aktuell keine kühlung verwendet das wasser was wir oben quasi gesehen haben
natürlich haben wir das wasser in bielefeld runtergekühlt wird dieses wasser fließt durch diese
fetten plattenwärmetauscher und die sind dafür da um dann letztendlich das wasser was dann für
die kühlung unten verwendet wird also was dann durch die luftwärme schränke läuft dann letztendlich
runter zu kühlen wir haben hier noch mal zwei riesige tanks das sind auch es ist auch das gleiche
wasser mit 14 grad Celsius was wir unten gesehen haben pro tank 6700 liter noch mal es läuft auch
dauerhaft immer durch diese plattenwärmetauscher durch hilft natürlich erst mal um das wasser
ein bisschen einheitlicher von der temperatur zu haben da gibt es keine schwankungen weil es ist
eben auch ultra viel wasser 6700 liter gleichzeitig auch so viel ausfallssicherheit wenn man noch mal
insgesamt der logische weise vier tanks weil den gleichen raum gibt es ja auch wieder doppelt
dementsprechend kann selbst wenn mal irgendwas mit der kühlung auch nicht funktioniert dieses wasser
ja verwendet werden um erst mal weiter zu kühlen und es dauert ja auch eine gewisse zeit um das
wasser erst mal wieder zu erwärmen falls es im sommer allerdings dann zu warm wird und die
außenkühlung dann nicht mehr ausreicht wie gesagt die geht nur entspannt bis 12 grad Celsius
außentemperatur dann gibt es hier natürlich diese überdimensionale klimaanlage beziehungsweise
chiller also wir hatten auch ein chiller wieder funktioniert ist es genau das gleiche prinzip
einfach nur viel viel größer 87 kW leistungsaufnahme und das ist der kleine nebendran gibt es noch mal
einen größeren mit 140 aufnahme was natürlich auch der grund ist warum man versucht sowas so
wenig wie möglich zu verwenden weil das natürlich auch die effizienz vom rechten zentrum deutlich
senkt ja das natürlich wesentlich entspannter wenn man einfach die abwärme nach außen abführen
kann und nicht auf die klima geräte angewiesen ist klimaanlage ist teuer wir sind jetzt hier gerade in
der schleuse wir sind vorhin und auch im laufe des sages schon öfter hier durchgelaufen lustig
kann ich auch kurz was zu erzählen als mal bei im also nicht im normalen rechten zentrum dort wo
ich früher gearbeitet habe sondern in einem etwas kleineren das war im sechsten stock glaube ich
wenn ich mich da richtig richtig entsinne war das im sechsten stock aber übrigens wisst ihr warum
das eben das auch ist es ist auch ist es ist auch ist ihr wisst ihr warum das rechten zentrum im
sechsten stock gebaut wurde das war als ich noch beim provider war das war dort wo wir als
dienstleister uns um ein rechten zentrum gekümmert haben also das war nicht das normale rechten
zentrum das war im sechsten stock und wisst ihr warum das im sechsten stock war ist der hammer
da kommt ihr nie drauf da kommt ihr müsst gar nicht raten ich sag's euch das war im sechsten nicht
überschwemmung nein nein mitten in frankfurt nicht überschwemmung ganz einfach wenn hätte es
theoretisch im keller bauen können auch nicht günstig wenn hätte es theoretisch im keller
bauen können aber es war eine äußerst prestige angelegenheit für den vorstand wer einen autopark
platz im keller hatte und als jetzt die frage war machen wir die parkplätze weg und dafür das
rechenzentrum in keller haben die alle gesagt nein das rechenzentrum darf auf gar keinen fall in
keller weil wir brauchen unsere autoparkplätze ist kein spaß leute so was bescheuert kann ich
mir ähnlich on the fly ausgleichs kein witz doch das ist mein ernst das mein voller ernst nachdem
das bei diesem unternehmen so eine wahnsinnige prästige angelegenheit war haben die dann das
rechenzentrum sechsten stock gebaut so sechster stock was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich ursprünglich
erzählen genau und eines tages das habe ich mitbekommen da war ich nicht live dabei eines tages
ist dort wirklich meine klimaanlage aufgefallen ausgefallen das haben sensoren gemerkt halt wegen
raumtemperatur und so was und da mussten leute von der hotline das waren die einzigen die da
waren von der support hotline die haben da eigentlich nichts mit zu tun mussten dann rüber rennen
irgendwie bei nacht und nebel und mussten die fenster aufreißen da war glücklicherweise 5 grad
außentemperatur oder so was aber sind die rüber morgens um vier und die fenster aufgemacht um noch
irgendwie das ganze am leben zu halten bis die techniker das wieder zu laufen gebracht haben
ja das ist doch ist von der front quasi wir sind dann rüber um die fenster aufgemacht also man
kann mit außenluft ohne problem an rechenzentrum kühlen kein ding ja das worauf ich raus wollte
oder es ist tatsächlich besser als laufen klimaanlage das wäre tatsächlich im keller
nicht gegangen gut dass es im sechsten stock war der hintergrund schon mal auf dem anderen schild
gesehen es gibt hier sauerstoff reduzierter bereich und hier rechts zum beispiel das messgerät da
sehen wir 17,1 prozent sauerstoff haben wir in dem bereich in dem wir gerade reingehen wollen
verglichen mit der normalen umgebungsluft die hat circa 20 prozent diese 17 prozent sauerstoff
gehalt die deckt man sich nicht aus damit 17 prozent das ist dann wahrscheinlich so viel wenn
auf den berg geklettert bist oder so weißt du wie der wieder m course seinen youtube account wieder
bekommen hat ja der hat sich an youtube auf twitter gewandt zu atmen was tatsächlich nicht der fall
ist zumindest nicht subjektiv gesehen mir ist es gar nicht aufgefallen bis es mir gesagt haben
dann ist es mir auch nicht aufgefallen aber das war das man denkt glaube ich das aspekt denn bei
diesem sauerstoffgehalt brennt es weniger möglich eine offene flamme zu haben was natürlich auch
wichtig ist weil wir haben viele server hier die sehr viel energie aufnehmen dementsprechend die
werden sehr warm es gibt immer die gefahr dass irgendwas mal durch brennt es kann auch einfach
ein einfacher kondensator sein der mal durch brennt und man will natürlich absolut vermeiden dass
irgendwo ein brand entsteht wenn jetzt mal wir nehmen jetzt mal einfach mal einen kondensator
würde durch brennen irgendwo auf dem mainboard wenn wir es hier stehen wir würden das niemals
feststellen aber neben mir sehen wir jetzt mal so eine messanlage und es gibt hier insgesamt fast
2000 sensor überall verteilt im ganzen rechenzentrum zum beispiel auch in den kaltgängen oder außerhalb
von den kaltgängen was ist mit meinem ausweis ja ich habe einen ausweis jetzt ich habe einen
üh in den vorübergehenden ausweis wisst ihr wie ich das gemacht habe für alle die sich mitbekommen
haben ich wollte mir den ausweis holen und war bei der stadt hanau ich habe mehrere male dort
angerufen war immer halbe stunde lang in der warte schleife dann wieder neu angerufen halbe
stunde warte schleife es hat nicht funktioniert online wollte ich einen termin buchen es hat über
einen monat gedauert bis ich hätte einen termin bekommen und ich brauche einen ausweis ich muss
post in post ident machen und wisst ihr was ich gemacht habe letztendlich der chat hat mich auf
die idee gebracht chat ist wieder wirklich mvp gewesen ich habe bei einer anderen stadt angerufen
ich habe hier neben dran bei bei der stadtverwaltung angerufen und habe gefragt ist es ok wenn ich das
über euch mache in hanau kriege ich keinen ausweis so schnell kein termin haben die erst gemeint nein
das geht eigentlich nicht oder habe ich ihnen das vorgelesen was beim bundesinnenministerium auf
der webseite steht dass das doch geht und da habe ich gesagt ach so ja wenn das so ist dann müssen
wir uns noch mal an hanau wenden und aber kommen sie mal morgen vorbei und dann war ich dann morgens
bei dem anderen amt und die haben jetzt einen vorübergehenden ausweis gegeben easy jetzt habe
ich post ident gemacht also mein personalausweis ist abgelaufen was anderes habe ich nicht
post ident geht weder mit der krankenkassenkarte noch mit dem führerschein in dem führerschein
weiß ich nicht da hat zumindest der chat gesagt dass es nicht geht ja ist man verpflichtet aber
für den vorläufigen ausweis muss ich das noch nicht machen egal wir gucken jetzt weiter dass
da tatsächlich irgendwas passiert ist also auch wenn man es ist mit der menschlichen nase niemals
feststellen würde die sensoren sind so genau dass die kleinste partikel feststellen können wenn
irgendwo was schief läuft und dann kann man sich nur feststellen dass irgendwas passiert ist sondern
man kann dadurch dass es so viele sensoren haben kein reisepass wo ist es was passiert und rein
theoretisch könnte man dann auch ich reise nichts ich sitze daheim im keller und krieg keine sonne ab
wozu soll ich ein reisepass haben wenn man jetzt einfach mal so ein mainboard betrachtet und da
würde irgendwas durchbrennen dann habt ihr euren rauchschwaden dings was noch hoch geht und dann
denkt man sich natürlich was bringt mir das wenn ich jetzt irgendwo so ein sensor an der wand kleben
habe wie merkt ihr das überhaupt funktioniert eben weil es hier keine direkte verbindung zur
außenluft gibt also es gibt keine außenluft irgendwie durch ein fenster reinkommt fenster gibt
sowieso keine sondern man hat hier umluft ist aber auch logisch irgendwie weil wenn wir jetzt mal
angenommen irgendwie so einen kleinen schaden hätten irgendwo würden irgendwelche kleinen
partikel ausgasen dann muss man natürlich sicher ja wahrscheinlich wenn da einer zu viel zu oft
einfahren lässt das löst alarm aus dass sich das sehr sehr schnell homogen verbreitet damit man das
auch entsprechend detektieren kann das ist sehr sehr wichtig und wenn man das nicht machen würde
könne man ja auch nicht den sauerstoff so einfach absenken weil dann würde ja die ganze zeit sauerstoff
von außen nachkommen das wird nicht funktionieren aber abgesehen davon dass das natürlich sehr
aufwärts ich persönlich wusste gar nicht wie man das macht dass man überhaupt den sauerstoff
absenken kann also dass ich einfach ein bisschen sauerstoff aus der luft holen kann wie das
funktioniert das schauen wir uns jetzt an dazu gibt es jetzt neben mir diese oxy reduct anlage
heißt es ist einfach so ein oxy reduct technisch gesehen aber sehr interessant erst mal zu meiner rechten eurer linken
haben wir hier einen kompressor wo ist die zweite wo ist die zweite oxy reduct und der saugt von
außen durch diesen tunnel den wir sehen können saugt er außenluft an außenluft wie gesagt circa
20 prozent sauerstoff und das wird dann komprimiert und wird dann in diese maschine eingeleitet da
drin sitzt im embran die sauerstoff sind in gewissen anteil eben raus filtern kann das heißt das was
übrig bleibt von dem gas also wir haben ja stickstoff zum beispiel noch in der luft zum großen
anteil das bleibt dann alles drin und man hat dann eine sauerstoff reduzierte luft die man dann
nach unten geht alles riesen aufriss oder schon was man für einen sauerstoff in der luft haben will
mischt man das unten bei und kann dann wie gesagt zum beispiel war klar stimmt machen die nicht auch
pizzas rein theoretisch könnte das natürlich trotzdem soweit kommen dass irgendwo ein schweltband
entsteht seit es ist im server oder sonst wo und das wird dann wie gesagt detektiert durch viele
von diesen sensoren die da sind wenn gewisse grenzwerte überschritten werden würden dann könnte
man natürlich sagen ok wir wollen das löschen das funktioniert hiermit wir haben hier stickstoff
flaschen die auch ein bisschen größer sind als die normalen gasflaschen 300 bar druck hat so eine
schickstoff flasche also dass ordentlich was ordentlich druck drin relativ viele und das geht
dann hier oben über dieses ohr hier haben wir dann so eine verteileanlage wo man dann sieht
löschbereich 5 das ist wirklich ein dementsprechend zu dem löschbereich geleitet werden wo dann
gegebenenfalls im schwelbrand zum beispiel festgestellt wurde wichtig ist dabei natürlich
es ist klar wenn ganz viel schickstoff da eingeleitet wird dann verdrängt ist ja was man nicht
unterschätzen darf bei so einem bei so einem setup die haben natürlich ein super krass ausfall also
anti ausfall setup also da fällt nichts aus und wenn was ausfällt ist es doppelt vorhanden und
sowas aber was man da auch immer kalkulieren muss und das haben sie bestimmt gemacht es ist
immer so ein bisschen trade-off also für jedes sagen wir mal weitere nachkommas stelle ausfalls
sicherheit steigt die komplexität halt immer krasser an und irgendwann muss man sich halt
fragen handelt man sich durch die gestiegene komplexität nicht wieder unterm strich mehr
probleme ein als man durch die dadurch vorhandene ausfallssicherheit gewinnt das haben die sich
bestimmt alles gut überlegt da keine frage aber man sieht dass da wahnsinnig viel komplexität
drinnen steckt also da kann jetzt nicht nur was im prinzip ganz simples beispiel durch irgendwo
ein server stehen da macht alles so der kann kaputt gehen so bei diesem setup hast du allerdings
nicht nur ein server der kann kaputt gehen sondern du hast 30 milliarden sachen da geht laufend mal
was kaputt aber du hast halt so gebaut dass es nach möglichkeit nicht schlimm ist wenn an
einer stelle mehr was kaputt geht also aber die bei der komplexität muss natürlich auch
immer noch einer durchblicken das muss gewartet werden das muss teilweise erneuert werden die
sachen das ist nicht ohne also das kostet wahnsinnig viel kohle das heißt die umgebungsluft in der
wir dann vorher diese 17 prozent sauerstoff hatten die ist dann eben komplett voll mit sauerstoff
dementsprechend ist es für mensch natürlich so ist kein sauerstoff mehr vorhanden zum atmen
ist schlecht vorher entsprechende sirenen warnsignale dass man auch weiß was auf einen
dazu kommen würde und selbst wenn mir wurde gesagt selbst wenn es soweit kommt dass man das aus
welchen gründen auch immer vielleicht nicht mehr schafft ist es ja auch nur für einen ganz kurzen
zeitraum um das feuer quasi zu ersticken dann wird er wieder die luft eingeleitet und man
könnte weiteratmen also selbst wenn man dann kurz luft anhalten vielleicht im bereich weil man
unmächtig ist nicht mehr verlassen kann stirbt man nicht wir kommen jetzt so weit die theorie so
weit die theorie ich wette mit euch das haben sie noch nie getestet und werfen nochmal einen
zwischenblick auf die korser dominator und damit den sponsor dieses videos die korser dominator
platinium jetzt haben wir dominator platinium rgb und ermöglichen damit nahezu die doppelte
lesegeschwindigkeit ja aber auch für den fünffachen preis wahrscheinlich werden die module
übrigens durch die patentierte dhx kühlung von korser die in vielen unabhängigen tests auch
absolut überzeugen konnte handselektierte ram chips sorgen dabei für das perfekte zusammenspiel
der module und eine einfache verwendung schaffen dass wahrscheinlich der ram teurer ist als der
grafikkade port von intel xmp und damit geht es jetzt auch weiter mit dem video damit sind wir
soweit eigentlich erstmal durch durch das thema infrastruktur keine sorge das video geht auch
ein stück wir kommen noch zu den servonen allem aber wie ihr jetzt gesehen habt mehrfach in dem
thema infrastruktur also alles was jetzt stromversorgung betrifft die kühlung betrifft zieht
sich ja ganz klar durch dass es alles doppelt und dreifach vierfach teilweise gibt und wenn
man jetzt vielleicht an den normalen server zu hause denkt oder vielleicht an einen kleineren
betreiber der für den privatkunden vielleicht selber zur verfügung stellt dann ist sind es
natürlich ganz unterschiedliche ansprüche hier ist der anspruch dass 100 prozent leistung immer
verfügbar sind zum beispiel wir haben da ein system was wir uns nachher anschauen das ist ein
ibm mainframe ein haus ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr wie viele neun nach der nachkommensstelle
kommen aber wir hatten das gestern aus ein haus circa 52 sekunden down time in einem jahr also
jetzt nur statistisch betrachtet und warum das so wichtig ist ist natürlich wenn man jetzt mal
betrachtet wer die kunden von ödys sind ich weiß es nicht im namen wer die mit kobe natürlich
klar datenschutz technisch wird man das jetzt nicht verraten wer jetzt hier genau ein kunde
ist aber es betrifft natürlich viel mehr dinge die auch die infrastruktur von deutschland vielleicht
betreffen ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es vielleicht ein krankenhaus ist oder sie laufen
nicht auf hindurchs die laufen auf z.o.s wenn man dann denkt man hat jetzt vielleicht irgend so ein
ibm lkw die sind irgendwo unterwegs und die müssen dann irgendwo wahre abholen und dann hat man da sein
versandzentrum sein sein lagerhaus die lkw kommen alle an die lkw sollen wahre abholen und dann
funktioniert es plötzlich nicht schlecht dann staut sich das dann hat man vielleicht einen stau
auf der autobahn gleich ist wenn das vielleicht jetzt einfach mal in supermarkt betreffen würde
und jemand sitzt an der kasse und dann funktioniert die kasse nicht mehr das kommt natürlich aus
manche möglichkeiten sein wo man vielleicht dann wo es halt wirklich kritisch ist wenn man dann
sagt ich habe da was im hinterkopf eine stunde weg das kann man sich einfach bei solchen ich sag
man kritischeren dingen einfach nicht erlauben und das ist der grund warum die auch hier so
extrem auf alles achten dass alles immer funktioniert und egal unter welchen umständen
das ist was wo ich sagen muss was mich vor allem als ich jetzt das erste mal hier durchgelaufen
bin und so eine ganz kurze führung mal hatte um einzuordnen was wir hier video technisch alles
festhalten das hat mich also wirklich aus den socken gehauen also wirklich krass beeindruckt was für
den aufwand notwendig ist um jetzt einfach mein server zu betreiben weil am ende ist es für mich
so ja klar ich stelle da mein server hin und das war es so gefühlt und wenn man jetzt alles mal
betrachtet und wir haben schon versucht ist für euch ist eine haltung zu ibn produkten ganz
ehrlich das meiste zeug was für mich relevant ist ist mittlerweile bei lenovo wir haben keine
powerserver mehr das einzige was wir noch am start haben ist so ein IBM z-series ding und mit dem
habe ich so gut wie keine berührungspunkte ansonsten ist IBM bei uns zum größten teil raus
ich habe noch einen sinkpad aber das ja auch lenovo in der einen oder anderen stelle vielleicht noch
was wo man es noch mehr im detail hätte machen können aber ich glaube ihr habt jetzt schon
mal einen guten eindruck bekommen was für ein aufwand dahinter steckt einfach mal ein server
zu betreiben der halt immer da ist wir sind jetzt im rechten zentrum bei ödiv und wir haben hier
neben mir einfach eine unfassbare maschine das ist ein IBM power 10 ein power 10 ist erkennbar an
e 1080 also die 10 davor steht eben für die generation und wenn wir es einfach mal schon
draufschauen das ist gar nicht so spektakulär aus wie das was dahinter zu sehen ist also wir
haben hier vier verschiedene notes in die der server unterteilt ist also eigentlich so eine
maschine hier sehen können aber warum stehen die das verstehen warum stehen die so auf power pc
dinger das ist doch eigentlich also die letzten zehn jahre nicht mehr irgendwie wahrscheinlich
einfach weil es schon immer gemacht haben oder so hier noch drin sitzen das ist eine note hier
unten da läuft aber nichts mehr gescheit drauf außer vielleicht IBM eigenes zeug steuereinheit
die control unit ohne diese control unit würde power 10 gar nicht starten aktuell ist das ding
aus weil wir gleich von hinten uns ein bisschen anschauen können im idealfall auch so ein bisschen
in reinschauen können ich mal gespannt was ihr dann zu gesicht bekommt nun mal so ein paar
ekdaten zu nennen srp stuff monka ist 92 kerne 64 terabyte ram in der maximalen ausdrucks stufe
kann der power 10 240 kerne das ist jetzt hier nicht der fall aber 192 kerne ist auch schon sehr
sehr beeindruckend und ja was noch beeindruckender ist für mich persönlich so ein bisschen ist der
preis so eine maschine ich kenne ihn und weiß nicht aber die liegt im siebenstelligen bereich
der kostet millionen und und was witzig ist also ich weiß bloß bei bei ab ab im haus beziehungsweise
z-series geräten ist es ja irgendwie so dass du das kaufst aber es dir nie richtig gehört du bezahlst
im endeffekt für rechenzeit auf den kisten also das steht in deinem rechenzentrum du hast das
gekauft du hast das bezahlt aber du bezahlst für die rechenzeit die du nutzt darauf noch mal also
das ist ich weiß nicht wie es bei den dingern ist aber das ist irgendwie sehr merkwürdiges zeug
was IBM da treibt hier ist es ein bisschen leise zumindest für mich für euch macht es wahrscheinlich
keinen großen unterschied aber wir haben jetzt möglicherweise ein techniker von IBM da weil
fun fact auch wenn ödiv diesen ganzen server hier hat das ist deren rechenzentrum ödiv darf
diese server nicht öffnen das ist komplett verrückt also wenn man das ist mal mit so einem
typischen infoserver vergleicht da geht man hin das ist so das ist halt so best enterprise stonks
bullshit das ist der eigene server hier die IBM server die kostet millionen und dann können die
die aber nicht selber warten ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen gewährleistungsthema weil die
server so teuer sind sagt IBM nur der IBM techniker ja ja ich weiß das ist das kenne ich deswegen
mussten wir auch extra einen passenden termin haben dass ein server von IBM auch extra hierher kommt
nur um den server für uns aufzumachen dass wir uns das eine oder andere mal ja den plötzlich
also es ist so unfassbar laut hier drin ist dieser IBM power 9 server der macht einfach unfassbar
das ist die generation die es vorher gab also power 9 interessanterweise seht ihr seht der
unterschied ist der alte hat grüne leds der neu hat blaue leds da hinten sitzen lüfter
das sind auch die die so rumgrölen die ganze zeit wenn wir jetzt mal zu dem power 10 kurz
noch mal rüberschauen dann seht ihr der power 10 hat auch keine durchgehende blende mehr weil
die sagen diese blende mit der wapen struktur ist schon so ein widerstand für die lüfter und für
den luftstrom weil der power 10 so power hungrig ist wortwörtlich dass man das eben nicht mehr
machen kann IBM sagt viel wenn der tag lang ist der power 9 war das noch nicht notwendig wir sind
auf der rückseite und bevor wir den jetzt gleich ausbauen interessanterweise diese kabel hier das
sind die kabel die werden hier oben angesteckt und die führen dann direkt zur cpu das heißt
alles hier untereinander ist untereinander verknüpft also jede cpu also die dinger kenne ich nicht was
ich von uns aus kenne ist IBM z-series diese dinger kenne ich von uns ja so sehen die von
vorne aus sieht ein bisschen abgespacet aus solche solche dinger ist aber ähnlich ja darf
auch nur der zertifizierte IBM techniker dran und du musst sogar die cpu zeit bezahlen und
unter diesen unterschiedlichen modulen über diese kabel verknüpft das wäre jetzt zum
Beispiel einfach mal eine netzwerkkarte wie die in dem power 10 verbaut ist wenn man hier mal die
abdeckung aufmacht das kommt ein bisschen mehr bekannt vor also hier sieht man dann ist ein ganz
normaler pc express 16 fachslot die leute solche verträge ein das weiß ich auch nicht so genau
ehrlich gesagt bei uns ist es halt so dass die relativ viel ollen kobold shit haben ich meine
bank und sowas der halt wohl super optimiert auf diesem IBM kram läuft es gab bei uns immer
mal wieder bestrebungen das ding endlich rauszuschmeißen aber es haben sie noch nicht
nicht hinbekommen und das geht dann hier vorne sogar im sata stecker noch und das ist das was
letztendlich im server landet wir haben jetzt hier einen techniker von IBM vor Ort und der
baut jetzt für uns mal den power 10 soweit auseinander wie wir können natürlich können
wir nicht vollständig auseinander bauen zum beispiel wir können keine cpu rausnehmen weil
einfach das risiko zu groß ist weil die cpus einfach unfassbar teuer sind deswegen beschränken
wir uns auf das was halt geht ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt gleich zu gesicht bekommen jetzt noch
kurz der blick von vorne der server bewegt sich auch gerade so ein bisschen zu mehr raus ja das
ist der den wir uns gleich anschauen werden ihr seht es schon die blende ist weg hier unten
drunter sind die netzteile die redundanzen wir haben vier netzteile jedes von denen 1150 watt
auch die lüfter sind sehr krass ich bin gespannt wie laut die sind wenn wir die mal rausfahren aber
auch diesen komplett modulat werden gepauscht werden falls irgendwelche probleme vorliegen also
also das zeug wie gesagt ich kenne es nur hinter IBM Playcenter wenn die mal voll
hoch drehen das hat ganz schön wumms diese lüfter haben wir gewisse höhen einheiten also
normalerweise dürfen die power einheiten nicht über 24 eingebaut werden weil dann einfach das
gewicht so hoch ist und die haben sich eine sondergenehmigung von IBM geholt dass sie
die bis ganz oben bauen dürfen dazu mussten sie aber extra leiter und helm von IBM kaufen ganz
richtig wir haben es vor uns den offenen power 10 und vom aufbauen her ist es zwar irgendwie
ähnlich zu dem power 5 aber auch trotzdem was ganz anderes wir haben IBM verträge hier
nebeneinander sitzen ist vor allem die kabelverbindung die hier von außen reinkommt so ist
halt die enterprise welt die kabelverbindung die geht direkt zu cpu das heißt wir haben hier keine
kommunikation wie wir das von normalen server aus kennen oder von normalen pc aus von der cpu
übersockel irgendwie übers mainboard sondern die kabel gehen wirklich leiter dm u seitlich rein
ein bisschen da unten das ist das schwarze stecker die seitlich in die cpu reingehen und da ist
quasi kabel direkt in die cpu angeschlossen wir nehmen jetzt einmal ein speichermodul raus das ist
auch ein bisschen anders als die speichermodule die wir bisher gesehen haben ist auch eine ganz
andere schnittstelle dieses speichermodul hat 256 gigabyte kapazität ddr4 hier unten ist die
schnittstelle mit dem es okay das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen wir haben so ein kleines
körper drauf unter ist ein controller für diesen das nennst du hier links und rechts
haben ein speicherschiff da kackt korsar aber jetzt dagegen ab oder da können sie noch so
sehr mit vengeance und dominator rgb ram ankommen auf der rückseite auch nochmal insgesamt dann
eben 256 gigabyte pro modul hier um die spannungsversorgung für den ram regel und
wenn wir uns jetzt eben anschauen wie viele hier drin sind dann kommt man insgesamt auf
16 terabyte speicher in diesem server so das ganze ist zusammengebaut und ich habe jetzt die
ehre den schaub noch zu drücken normalerweise darf man das nicht als nicht-idm-techniker ich weiß
auch nicht warum die anderen so machen wahrscheinlich ist einfach ein paar fucking laut aber nix passiert
jetzt geht ab jetzt geht ab jemals flugzeug startet
ja ungefähr so muss man sich das vorstellen also ganz so krass es ist hinter einem play center
wo du lüfter rauch wo du netzteile rausziehst nicht also so heftig ist es nicht aber es
bläst schon ordentlich man stellt sich natürlich wahrscheinlich die frage wozu überhaupt
idm power sowas ja das frage ich mich wirklich warum warum und der hauptunterschied ist natürlich
auch erst mal die riesige menge ram die man da verwalten kann ja das kann die satsache wie
die verfügbarkeit von dem system aus so bei den idm power system ist einfach die verfügbarkeit
wirklich das absolute maximum das heißt die sind immer verfügbar und sind enorm schnell was die
zugriffsgeschwindigkeit beim ram z.b. das überzeugt mich jetzt nicht so wirklich das klingt eher nach
idm marketing material dieses idm power 10 system der ram zugriff also die geschwindigkeit läuft mit
1600 gigabyte pro sekunde das muss man sich jetzt einfach mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen ist
erstmal eine unfassbar große zahl aber wenn wir jetzt mal auf so ein normales inklotter amd desktop
system schwanken dann haben wir da eine geschwindigkeit von circa 50 bis 60 gigabyte pro sekunde
das ist das das hängt ja von der anwendung ab also sprich was macht man da drauf
was das also das läuft immer noch nicht so genau deswegen hat man dann gewisse applicationen wie
z.b. jetzt sap hana oh Gott naja alles klar alles klar die komplette datenbank liegt komplett auf
dem ramm dann ist mir klar direkt hier im server mit drin oder irgendwie erst mal das muss ja
sap sein was sonst aber eine instanz die bei idm power haben läuft mit 14 terabyte ram und 400
kernen circa das ist halt unvergleichlich und diese maximale verfügbarkeit verglichen jetzt einfach
mit einem normalen x86 system kommt durch die höhere redundanz alles in diesem system existiert
eigentlich achtmal angefangen zum beispiel mit dieser spannungswanderkarte die wir gerade schon
gesehen haben was denn sonst das muss ja sap alle alles davon ist eben so oft vorhanden dass wenn
da mal was ausfällt das zu kein problem tut rein theoretisch kann hier sogar ein einzelner kern von
der cpu ausfallen die sind wahrscheinlich so tief auch in diesem sap ökosystem und eigenentwicklung
drinne dass die können gar nicht mehr anders das ist nicht möglich wenn bei einer intel cpu ein
kern ausfällt dann ist die cpu bestimmt das geht da gar nicht und hier ist es wirklich so alles
aber eigentlich auch kein ding also du kannst aus also du kannst hochverfügbarkeit auch relativ
gut auf einer ebene oben drüber abfackeln das ist eigentlich kein kein problem gerade in zeiten von
mikro von von micro services und sonst was also das ist halt das ist halt eher die old school
variante alles auch in cpm modus zum beispiel was auch wichtig ist wie oft verreckt eigentlich
öfters als du denkst wenn du so ein fettes ding hast und wenn du dir überlegst wie viele
tausende hardware komponenten da verteilt sind übers rechenzentrum dann wird wahrscheinlich schon
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob täglich was sein wird aber bestimmt alle paar tage mal irgendwo was
kaputt gehen ich glaube das geht gar nicht anders du hast so viel was du an hardware hast und
dementsprechend auch so viel was kaputt gehen kann zwar ist das potenziell natürlich etwas
langlebiger als jetzt vielleicht irgendwas was du daheim hast aber trotzdem ist es genug denke
es ich denke es geht da öfters was kaputt als man denkt 80 prozent tatsächlich ist x86 ja gut
und das ist jetzt das verstehe ich diese das verstehe ich jetzt ja 80 prozent x86 und für so
special shit haben die halt noch power dinger ok das leuchtet mir ein weil ich wollte gerade sagen
was willst du heute großartig noch mit abm power pc machen aber ok das leuchtet ein 80 prozent
80 prozent x86 zeug für die feldwald und wiesen standard zeug und für irgendwelchen
spezial krempe den sie wahrscheinlich in den letzten 30 jahre selbst entwickelt haben auch
dann power pc ok das leuchtet mir ein hinter einem ganz normalen server das ist das was die
meisten wahrscheinlich so als als server verstehen würden ist dieser typische server den man so
kennt und hier sehen wir viele von denen übereinander gestapelt und zum vergleich jetzt mal rechts da
nebendran das sind dann sogenannte blade server der unterschied ist dass wir ein chassis haben
also ein gehäuse in das diese blade server eingeschoben werden wir haben ganz schön viele
die sehen aber ganz anders aus als die alten zeig die mal von vorne ich kenne nur die alten
ja wo beispielsweise hs 22 23 23 reinkommen ja die kenne ich noch
so ungefähr die weiß ich nicht ob es exakt die sind diese dinger kenne ich noch
das ist das hier ist ein einzelner server den du rein steckst da hast du zum
beispiel den hs ibm hs 22 reingesteckten hs 22 ist so ein ding hier zwei cpus mit
jeweils was ich 16 kern oder sowas ja so so sah der krempe aus ok das ist jetzt die
ultra oldschool variante ja sind playcenter seit virtualisierung nicht eher outdated ja also
playcenter sieht man tatsächlich wenig in letzter zeit gibt es nicht mehr wirklich viele ich meine
playcenter haben sie eignet sich halt auch wunderbar als esx cluster letztendlich aber ja es ist schon
nicht mehr so der ja schon nicht mehr so verbreitet wie das wie das früher war
hier links und rechts 3000 cpu kenne vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr und wir haben circa 80
terabyte ram über diese zwei schränke verteilt wenn wir jetzt zurückdenken an ibm power da hatten
wir auf gefühlte hälfte von der höhe der hälfte der hälfte der hälfte der hälfte
auf gefühlte hälfte von der höhe hier und 60 terabyte ram also sieht man halt wie
höher die rammdichte bei ibm power ist gegenüber jetzt diesen x86 maschine der kostet aber
wahrscheinlich auch 20 mal mehr gesehen haben sehen wir es hier von vorne und hier seht ihr
auch diese einzelnen einstuhlfächer also eins so eine maschine hier das ist ein einzelner
playserver der eben reingeschoben das sind doch gar keine ibm plates aber sind sysco plates ok
da hatten wir mal die hat die habe ich selbst noch nie benutzt da hatten wir nur mal testweise ein
paar da die habe ich noch nie wirklich also nie wirklich so groß was mitgemacht das sind
sysco plates und da sitzen dann die zwei sockel drauf wie sowas aufgebaut ist das schauen wir
jetzt mal eben im detail an und generell ist es so dass im zweiten video das wir machen da nehmen
wir mehrere verschiedene maschinen davon auseinander da seht ihr das dann noch mehr im detail aber
einschauen wir uns das an wir schauen uns jetzt beispielhaft an den sysco m4 blade server an
die sind deutlich länger die wir gerade gesehen haben war zwar m5 aber vom aufbau her quasi
identisch könnten da natürlich andere oder neuere sockel haben zum beispiel oder andere
ram bestückung mehr ram hier haben wir jetzt 512 gigabyte ram was ich persönlich an dem ganzen
design sehr interessant finde ist wenn man die zwei heatsinks miteinander vergleicht dann sieht
man dass die erste cpu deutlich breitere lamellen hat als die zweite cpu was natürlich auch dem
geschuldet ist die luft strömt hier durch das bedeutet die erste cpu bekommt tendenziell
kühlere luft ab als die zweite und deswegen hat die zweite einfach eine viel höhere finden
dicht in dementsprechend höhere oberfläche und kann dann mit wärmer luft genauso gut kühlen wie
die cpu die wir vorne sehen ansonsten was hier nicht vorhanden sind aktuell sind irgendwelche
laufwerke und hinten der bereiche laufwerke die laufwerke die laufwerk also in der regel
kannst du bestimmt die möglichkeit da irgendwie ssd so vielleicht noch einzumachen aber in der
regel hast du so du hast ein dass du hast vielleicht 12 usb und dvd laufwerk oder was auch immer an dem
eigentlichen platzer daran wenn du es wirklich brauchst und muss dann in muss dann quasi den
input um switchen auf welches plate du das jetzt legen willst und der storage ist meistens über
irgendein storage netzwerkgeschichte angebunden also die dinger brauchen eigentlich keinen eigenen
storage installieren flach natürlich hier sind aber jetzt einfach nur netzwerkarten installiert
bei unserer letzten kleinen zwischendurchrechnung kommen jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu den
cause dominator dominator der fünf speichermodulen die hitspattern sind die bei den modulen aus
aluminium gefertigt und sowohl in schwarz als auch in weiß erhältlich zusätzlich befinden
also wenn laufwerke 12 leuchtstärke dann wahrscheinlich immer noch die von ich die
könnt ihr über cause aber die meisten haben gar keinen laufwerk mehr ob einfache regenbogenbeleuchtung
oder euer komplett eigener effekt hier ist wirklich alles möglich weiterführende informationen
findet ihr wie üblich über den link in der beschreibung und damit geht es jetzt auch weiter
mit dem video abseits von den inklass x86 und den normalen IBM power gibt es auch noch was
das heißt im mainframe das steht fürs IBM z15 z für zero downtime wenn man sich das jetzt mal
wirklich überlegt in zahlen gesehen das z steht wirklich für zero downtime das hat sich doch
eben im marketing menschen letzten paar jahren ausgedacht also gesagt die haben 20 jahre im
betrieb und die hatten innerhalb von 20 jahren keinen einzigen ausfall also nicht keine sekunde
das ist natürlich unverstellbar dass solche maschinen so lange laufen man muss dazu aber
auch sagen dass diese maschine jetzt nicht 20 jahre hier schon läuft sondern alle fünf
jahre werden diese maschinen ausgetauscht und kommt dann auf den neuesten stand spätestens
alle fünf jahre das ist jetzt 15 das neueste system das sind die kisten die du kaufen kannst
aber du selbst noch die rechenzeit drauf bezahlen musst hier im mainframe hat die besonderheit dass
es sehr sehr alt ist von der kundentwicklung 1960 circa das ist richtig krass als gut es ist immer
noch das gleiche man benutzt immer noch die gleiche basis mainframe das heißt alle programme die
reich und 60 dafür gemacht wurden die würden hier auch immer noch laufen jetzt aber natürlich
wesentlich schneller als damals das heißt man muss keine programme übersetzen man kann alle
programme immer noch benutzen hat jetzt aber die hardware von zum beispiel 2020 die dann natürlich
angeblich gibt es die möglichkeit da jetzt auch liluks drauf drauf laufen zu lassen sehr zeitkritische
transaktion zum beispiel für banken und versicherungen die benutzen mainframe z oder eine börse zum
beispiel das das weiß ich aus erster hand bei allen systemen die wir uns bisher angeschaut haben mit
vielleicht ein paar ausnahmen haben die alle kein storage dabei also keine nvme ssd sartre ja das
ist normal was auch immer man sich vorstellen könnte sondern das ist komplett noch mal in einem
anderen raum da kommen wir auch noch gleich zu aber die daten müssen auch irgendwie übertragen werden
und die sollten auch möglichst schnell übertragen werden und das haben wir hier mal beispielhaft
alles was hier so schön rosa aussieht das ist fiber channel also eine glasfaser verbindung in
diesem fall mit 32 oder wobei man ja sagen muss ich finde das ich finde das verwirrend das deswegen
ist das glaube ich den meisten leute nicht klar fiber channel ist das protokoll das ist nicht
zwangsläufig weil es glasfaserkabel sind das ist benahmung aus der hölle ja du kannst auch
theoretisch fiber channel über über 45 kupferkabel machen heißt dann ein bisschen anders aber sind
ich zwangsläufig glasfaserkabel das ist wieder benahmung wir ja ja aber fiber channel ist so
dass das wirklich das verbreitet in der richtung kann mir immer nicht merken wie diese dicken
stecker heißen sind das lc stecker die klein sind lc stecker oder ach was weiß ich wie viele wie
viele 30 oder 64 gigabit pro sekunde ist aber schon neueres fiber channel also eins und eine
einzige verbindung kann dann dementsprechend zum beispiel acht gigabyte pro sekunde übertragen
ist natürlich schon extrem schnell das ganze ist dann aber nur für das 45 wird von glasfaserkabel
abgelöst wenn das wird beides parallel bestehen bleiben es hat alles seine vorzüge bzw. seine
nachteile zum beispiel wenn du richtig schnelle sachen drüber machen 10 gigabit aufwärts
die lc sind die kleinen ss sind die großen vier kick dann ist natürlich bei kupfer schwierig
also du machst du machst über über kupferkabel jetzt selten richtig lange strecken mit wahnsinnig
geschwindigkeit das hast du mit glasfaser deutlich besser glasfaser braucht auch gerade bei 10 gigabit
aufwärts weniger strom also sowohl modul technisch als auch netzwerkarten technisch
brauchen die kupferkabel mehr strom also es hat alles seine daseinsberechtigung das schöne an
kupferkabel ist dass kupferkabel halt oftmals vorhanden sind bzw. alte verkabelung verwendet
werden kann und dass das in der regel natürlich auch günstiger ist glasfaserkabel sind relativ
teuer gerade wenn man da noch module für braucht wo man die rein steckt also es hat alles es hat
alles seine seine seine vornachteile also wenn ich ein haus bauen würde ich habe ja hier das haus
vom opa renoviert ganz ehrlich im haus gebrauch wahrscheinlich würde ich immer noch wenn ich
wirklich neue sachen machen würde ich beides machen warum nicht weil nun aber du wirst im
privatbereich also im heimbereich eigentlich weiterhin kupfer haben also du hast zwar vielleicht
die ein oder anderen consumerprodukte die mal sfp plus port haben wo du auch module reinstecken
kannst für glasfaserkabel oder sowas aber es wird auch in zukunft im heimbereich wird das
hauptsächlich kupferkabel sein wenn wir nie glasfaser sehen im großen stil das kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen 10 gigabit switcher sind gar nicht mehr so teuer und selten du kriegst von
mikrotik welche immer gut wenn du jetzt wenn du jetzt welche suchst mit keine ahnung 48 port sfp
plus 10 g dann kostet natürlich was also kriegst von mikrotik relativ günstig welche 10 gigabit
switcher oder du kriegst von ubiquity wenn dir das mehr gefällt kriegst auch relativ günstig in 12
port sfp plus für 500 euro und als sfp 12 port sfp plus switch und 4 port 10 g rj 45 kupfer die
gehen also die sind gar nicht so teuer 10 gigabit switcher mittlerweile irgendwie direkt auf den
server zugreifen können ach ja und poe poe geht natürlich auch nur über kupfer richtig
zum beispiel man will irgendwas administrieren oder sowas dafür gibt es dann ganz normale
netzwerkverbindung über switches das wäre dann das hier das ist dann einfach nur eine 1g verbindung
also ein gigabit verbindung wenn man was datenintensiveres hat gibt es dann oben
drüber das ganze noch mal als glasfaser in dem fall jetzt 25 gigabit das sind dann diese
türkis farbenen und auch hier deswegen haben wir beide schränke aufgemacht wenn man darauf
achtet bei den switches zum beispiel diese netzwerkabel gibt es einmal in grün auf der
linken seite und wenn wir dann zur rechten seite wieder rüber geben dann sieht man hier bei
diesem switch sind die kabel in rot also auch hier ist es wieder so auch wenn es jetzt zwei
einzelne schränke es ist aber alles muss man in echt etwas äußerst ordentlich einheit weil auch
hier können es ja wieder so sein dass ein schrank zum beispiel die stromversorgung von
einem schrank fällt aus dann ist der ganze schrank aus weswegen gibt es dann das gleiche
eben noch mal in dem zweiten schrank warum sollten die 10 gigabit machen 10 gigabit hardware ist um
ein vielfaches teurer und 1g rein für management sachen reicht doch dicke aus
für für management geschichten ist doch 1g das ist doch ab mehr als ausreichend
vollständig zu haben was ich schon wieder sehr sehr sympathisch finde ist die tatsache dass man
hierbei mit range storage anfängt das heißt irgendwie entran storage gibt es gar nicht
so lassen die jemand ins rechten zentrum nur ja wahrscheinlich weil es unter strich werbung für
sie ist und vielleicht kennen kennt er ja auch privat jemand da keine anruf also bei uns wäre
es schwierig weil bei uns sind die prinzipiell allem abgeneigt ich habe mit dem felix zusammen
aber uns war es im rechen zentrum aufgenommen habe ich immer noch nicht geschnitten und immer
noch nicht hochgeladen das haben wir schon vor über einem jahr aufgenommen von vor zwei jahren
auch vor corona haben wir das aufgenommen und enterprise diese seite hier sind quasi die
produktiven daten und hier liegen einfach gesagt die backups ist ganz einfach zu sagen die backups
verbrauchen aber ein vielfaches vom speicherplatz ja von den produktiven daten weil die eben mehrfach
gebacked werden auch zu unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten zum beispiel ist immer ein riesen
ding oder generell backup und archife sind sind richtig richtig speicherfresser für ibm z-series
die die kisten ihrer freund gezeigt hat gibt es auch richtig oldschool sachen das gibt ibm tape
libraries das sind dann solche dinger weiß nicht ob man irgendwo ein gescheites bild sieht mit
greifarmen drin das sieht richtig abgedreht aus ja sowas das sind magnetbänder die dann von so
einem greifarm getauscht werden ach kommt auch noch wirklich cool ja mal zu den enterprise
solutions wir haben jetzt hier ein delimc powermax was wir mal aufmachen können und das sind jetzt
die bereiche wo dann letztendlich die ganzen daten mal geschweitet werden was ich cool finde
ist jeder eins der von diesen einschügen wenn wir jetzt hier mal drauf schauen da wo die led blinkt
7,68 terabyte und alle diese teile die hier sehen können wo es schön blinkt das ist alles
ssd ist also mechanische lauferge es ist teuer 8 terabyte ssd alles was wir hier sehen können
die dinger sind teuer ich mein du kriegst du kriegst im privatbereich glaube ich mittlerweile
vier halbwegs aber die sache ist halt die das sind dann auch noch super krasse enterprise dinger
da wird wahrscheinlich eine ssd 5000 euro kosten oder so 8 tb ssd ja das sind keine kubo garantiert
nicht anderen sieht man gar nicht das sind jetzt endlich die quasi steuereinheiten für
die ganzen ssd also zum beispiel rate controller dahinter sitzen die dann diese ganzen ssd
verwalten wusste ich nicht auch hier ganz und das ist kein cool oder nur besonders geschrieben
anzahl wie oben lauter 7,68 terabyte ssd das letzte glied in der kette ist diese
library und das sind wir doch hätte ich mal ein bisschen weitergeguckt selber früher noch
als ich mal bei der bundeswehr servo wartung gemacht hat ist vielleicht ein bisschen länger
her im prinzip das ist richtig ausgutschett man hat hier drin bender greifarmen wir haben
auch aufnahm für euch gemacht der greifarmen ja laufwerke da können tapes eingeschoben
werden das passiert ganz automatisch von so einem armen das kenne ich doch automatisch
jetzt tapes einlegen und ausnehmen kann das ist auch so ein ding können die ganzen tausend
schon mal und ist als backup quasi verfügbar sind können die noch mal auf diese tapes
gesichert werden vorteil davon ist natürlich dass diese übrigens einfach wisst ihr wisst
ihr warum die tape warum das ding wechselt also nicht nur aber einer der gründe warum
diese diese diese tapes gewechselt werden das ist weil tapes kleben da muss die tapes regelmäßig
wechseln und bewegen dass die dass die nicht dass sie nicht festkleben das ist richtig
ausgutschett und die haben keine elektrische verbindung zum beispiel zu irgendwas also die
können ja nicht ausgelesen werden das bedeutet auch gleichzeitig wenn irgendwas katastrophal
schief laufen würde mit keine alle serverschränke fackeln ab oder wie auch immer dann ist es
immer noch so dass alle daten natürlich mit einem gewissen zeitversatz vielleicht einen
tag zum beispiel dann trotzdem hier komplett verfügbar ist glaube ich das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube nicht dass das komplette rechenzentrum darauf ist dass das IBM zeug da drauf ist
kann ich mir vorstellen aber bestimmt nicht alles wobei warum nicht die storage systeme
vielleicht werden die wirklich da drauf wobei das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen
übrigens 30 terabyte kapazität und ich dachte immer so tapes so ein bisschen outdated so wie
eine vhs zum beispiel aber 30 terabyte kapazität ist schon sehr sehr viel insgesamt haben wir hier
bei dem storage bereich gerade waren alles petabyte an daten und wir haben ja schon am
anfang gesagt dass wir zwei rechenzentren hier in bielefeld haben und jetzt dass die daten die
auf diesen backup storage liegen die werden nicht direkt hier beschrieben auf diesen bändern sondern
die werden erst im anderen rechenzentrum auf die bänder und die daten von dem backup storage von
dem anderen rechenzentrum die landen dann erst mal hier die werden zwar auch wieder synchronisiert
aber so schafft man es dass man eben direkt eine räumliche trennung hat nicht nur von dem storage
zu hier sondern direkt auch noch in das andere rechenzentrum damit sind wir jetzt tatsächlich
am ende angelangt von unserer tour durch das rechenzentrum ja da kommt es dir wirklich vor ich
kenne so dinge auch kommt es dir wirklich vor wie im letzten jahrtausend es hat aber es hat eine eine recht hypnotische wirkung
dazu zu gucken ich habe da schon teilweise 20 30 minuten davor gestanden wenn ich auf
irgendwas gewartet habe und habe diesem abend zu geguckt tapes hin und her zu schieben es war das
absolut beeindruckendste was ich je gesehen habe in der it welt einfach nur der ganze aufwand der
dahinter steckt um so ein rechenzentrum zu betreiben und das ganze lässt sich auch in eine zahl fassen
es gibt da so eine zahl die so ein bisschen die effizienz beschreit und dieses rechenzentrum hat
einen faktor von 1,35 das bedeutet 1,0 zum beispiel bedeutet man hat alle energie man verwendet nur
für die it also für die server zum beispiel wenn man ein faktor von 2,0 hat dann würde man sagen
dass man die gleiche energie die man in die server gesteckt hat noch mal braucht für alles außen
rum für die ganze infrastruktur für kühlung und so weiter generell sagt man dass ab 1,5 schon
grandioses und das hier hat 1,35 da sieht man auch auf welchem technischen stand das war was wir
hier heute angeschaut haben und generell in deutschland sind die rechenzentren im schnitt bei 2,0 also das
hier wirklich top dass man jetzt wissen wie sich das zusammensetzt und deswegen war es für mich
auch eine absolute ehre dass wir hier sein durften vielen dank noch mal an ödiv an dominic chris
marvin an die crew die uns jetzt die tage hier begleitet haben und das ganze mögen ich drache
klos wusste ich nicht also mir hat auch mal jemand erzählt deswegen ich habe mir das ja
nicht ausgedacht wer hat jemand erzählt das wird unter anderem wechselt dass es nicht festklebt
ja ja der chat wie immer wieder und ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen war ein schöner
einblick macht es gut bis zum nächsten mal ja trotzdem leises video ja so sieht es aus
ja so oder so ähnlich sieht es in vielen großen rechenzentren auf aus jetzt vielleicht nicht
unbedingt in exakt der gleichen ausführung aber da hängt schon einiges dran ist schon
heftig weiß ich ob einer von euch mal im dezix auf der hanauer landstraße war da ist auch
einiges an aufrissen generell also rechenzentrum betreiben ist so eine wissenschaft für sich man
hat ja gesehen da hängt so viele sachen dran von kühlung bis ausfallsicherheit bis brandschutz
backup konzepte stromausfälle und sonst was ich kann es verstehen dass gerade auch viele kleinere
sagen hey warum gehen wir nicht in die cloud und lassen es jemanden machen der ahnung davon hat
was ist deine meinung zu cloud backup ist so super geschichte kann man machen aber natürlich nur
verschlüsselt logischerweise also nix nix unverschlüsselt in die cloud pumpen kann man machen aber nur aber
nur wenn du das auch wirklich selbst verifizieren dass das jetzt verschlüsselt wird also mich
irgendwie eine software nehmen die sagt ja wir verschlüsseln ist und da hat es hoch am besten
ist du hast du verschlüsselt das selbst und schiebst an das erst danach hoch das ist natürlich die
beste variante wie würdest du die verschlüsseln kommt drauf an was ich machen will ja ich würde
wahrscheinlich sowas wie wie er klauen oder so verwenden oder in den backup tool was in
den open source backup tool was eben schon eingebaute verschlüsselung hat im zweifelsfall kann
sowas wie fs oder e-crypt fs oder sowas verwenden da kriegst du quasi in den ordner den mount ist
zu dir und unten drunter fallen die sachen verschlüsselt raus datei basiert und im anderen
ordner sind sie im klartext diese ordner kannst du direkt in die cloud spiegeln kommt bisschen
drauf an wie viel es ist was man machen will und und wieso die eigene infrastruktur ist ja die
noobs machen natürlich verschlüsselte 7 zip genau oder verschlüssel des vera kript laufwerk
aber verschlüssel des vera kript kript laufwerk ist für die cloud nicht gut weil der jedes mal
alles neu hochladen muss also für cloud backup ist auf jeden fall pflicht dass es datei basierte
verschlüsselung ist und nicht quasi ein großer container kenne ich nicht sagt mir nichts stable
mit cloud reif keine ahnung war das jetzt wieder war das war das werbe placement arbeitest du da
soll ich gehe jetzt was essen ich habe hunger und nicht dass ich nur abnehme gibt es irgendjemand
den wir hosten können ist keine ahnung außer leute mit 23.000 zuschauen die muss ich auch
nicht hosten die haben schon genug wie einsteine katze chico obwohl es obwohl es
obwohl es ein mädchen ist ach guck mal jvp den reden wir jetzt rate rate beim alles klar
leute also wir sehen uns dann entweder im nächsten video auf youtube oder im nächsten stream
bis dann macht's gut zu